so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
guy back to back
give it up for your champion
is this not some good ass tekken ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
tekken online challenge 2021 for the
oceania region i'm petra rose and we got
the one and only tasty steve all the way
from the ocean outside the ocean man
how's it going man
it's been it's been going pretty well
we're getting back to this online tekken
world uh it's been a minute since i've
uh seen you man but you've been doing a
great job holding it down
on that on that side of the world for
the tekken online challenges just to
take an online event in general it's
been cool it's a real place
i've been there i try to tell you they
say it's make-believe because the
insects over there are so big man i'm
trying to like make sure that they know
it's a real place yeah it's like some
dark soul stuff yeah it's legit
well it's all right we we get by we get
by
um but yeah of course dude i want to
thank astro the official headset and mix
amp of the ticket online challenge
keeping us uh you know keeping us fresh
and you know things are coming up and
we have
a big big tournament a big like for
australia online tournament this is
almost double than what we normally get
yeah we've been running like what like
two yeah yeah yeah yeah uh normally we
get around the 64 dojo 32 plus dojo but
this one's like almost 120 it's like 110
around that kind of people signed up so
that's really interesting i got the
stats here i've got all the facts and
figures that i collected we're talking
about like new zealand did like roughly
forty percent of the entries
around sixty
yeah yeah yeah so a lot of people from a
lot of regions have tried to jump in on
this opportunity because
if you look at the the uh leaderboards
everything is very close it's like this
this masters event is going to be so
disruptive to the whole order of things
because we look at the blanks right here
exactly like the winner will get 300
immediately getting first spot and we're
talking about like all the way into
i would say top eight has the ability
like 45 points at the seventh place
right
that will knock it that will knock out
half the competition right then and
there
should not feel comfortable like they
have to fight yeah that's actually
absolutely not true
points are definitely on the line points
are on the line and i love saying that
one two uh just the fact that it's the
battle is happening inside the oceanic
oceania region like that's what i really
want to see and i was going to ask you
how does like the online competition
stack up like i know we see like a lot
of like streamers from all these other
regions we see like the heavier names
what were some of the people
in the bracket do we have some of those
people that are like online monsters
playing from these specific i would say
yeah yeah definitely um there's
the big names that you should be looking
out for is like genuine gaming's dion
grey
he's been like i've got all the the top
eight placements of all the dojo events
that have happened this year and he's
got the majority of the wins like
whenever he turns up is either first
and like i think once he was second or
something and like that's pretty much it
he dominates so he's very very on top of
it
that makes a lot of sense
that makes a lot of sense because deon
gray is on the winner's side of this top
eight already so he's not telling that
name makes a lot of sense i didn't mean
to interrupt you but i just wanted to
throw that tip
okay so
second name is gonna be 500 milligrams
trend per week
okay that name i i'll i'll give you the
skinny on that crap later but don't
worry about it this guy is no joke we
saw him in the invitational last year
and take an online challenge
he did the the versus uh dion gray back
then he had a different name it was uh
li minho i think
uh so that was his name yes now you know
who i'm talking about so yeah this guy
again if he if he's not winning his
second place against dion a very the
most consistent second place hitter
giving himself another 145 points it's
right up there
um that's my second name and then
there's a whole other bunch of like wild
cards that have been popping up lately
so there is definitely i would say and
the other big hitter from melbourne is
going to be chant ny
ah yes i remember origin but lives in uh
in australia now for many many years um
this guy is red-hot but he doesn't
really have a big online presence he's a
it's a very traditional offline guy but
you know for whenever he does turn up to
online tournaments people get tense
because he just usually sweeps it
but now he's got a lot of heavy hairs at
the same time so as i said you've got
dion grey you've got um
uh you've got 500 mils you've got you
know all these other guys that also were
like harlem we've got like a daituka
we've got you know crazy new guys from
south australia south australia has been
dominating not dominating but like
making themselves known okay here
because south australia is a really
small region that doesn't have a lot of
offline presence but as soon as online
kicked in the past two years they have
been drilling it for a really long time
okay okay we've got people like you know
like um sorry uh subject we've got six
wheat picks and you know there's bobby
and all these guys that like go in and
create upsets so yeah we've got our
first match now okay interesting strong
first match we've got natural versus
winter bear i don't know who winter bay
is but natural is definitely a high
level new zealand player ah okay okay he
was also he came to uh evo um 2019. he
was one of the new new zealand crew
okay
what's up
did they do pretty well at that last
offline evo or were they just unattended
that was one of the toughest ones either
way so i would just be surprised yeah it
was really tough no joke no jerk
so yeah all i remember is that um they
did some money matches with porkchop and
it was not good for him but you know the
pork chops
a cheerleading squad and then like even
though he's tired he still gets powered
up you can never give him that but
in all honesty like oceana the region is
very very strong i don't believe i've
seen uh even like changing y since what
the last bam that i came out to in all
honesty i think so
so it's there's a lot of players there
and that last that last band that we
went to was actually ridiculous there
was a lot of international competition
but a lot of the players from that
region was sprinkled throughout that top
16 where there was a lot of matchups
where you had yeah and we got a couple
strands in top eight
like that was something red
so that was one of the good that was one
of the uh the times i the last time i
was there abs actually i think that was
the last time i was there actually when
we saw like all your amazing players
show up from the region and go up
against some of the best international
competition that top 16 that top eight
was absolutely ridiculous i remember
that oh yeah i can't wait to see you on
the ground
oh yes that's sweet oh the sweep of pain
like i just couldn't uh man i couldn't i
was right there dude i was front line
just like
witnessing witnessing young blood
that's all right that's good that was
good
well i mean hopefully uh it'll come back
to us one day but i just like seeing the
region get a lot of spotlight on it
especially when it's even like you guys
like when i see you and brown man
talking about these players man i really
get a sense for the region and i miss
traveling over there but the online is
doing the job just fine at this point so
i think we're getting into our first
match oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay
up against natural
yeah so um natural i was gonna say was a
high-level gin player but
as the seasons go by it kind of like you
know vacillates between other characters
but i was saying i was telling myself i
hope he just picks gin today and there
we go get the gin okay so yeah you got
what you want
to give them the best output you know
oh yeah but he's reversing julia which
is a little bit of a problem because
she dodged all the nerves she just
walked by you know
oh julia definitely got in with the she
definitely got in there with the yeah
i'm fine and she was not fine uh she's
definitely really good okay gets the
electric
oh nice gets the high wall splat two on
top of that all right natural looking
like one gets that first round pretty
clean round two
oh yeah
i've got high expectations for natural
in this tournament
oh gets the pair he didn't
okay starting to go into the pokes
i can see right now winter bear is uh
starting to notice the natural side
stepping a lot counter hit 4-4
gonna go for the carry
fights back to the middle of the stage
and winter bear is not really active
with this julian i'm not used to seeing
it
okay down forward
he doesn't need to take big risks just
chip
why risk it
wait it out give him a jab there we go
simple as round three why take big risks
there you go
okay two rounds in are ready for natural
wenzel bear
not able to get anything started the
counter head down 4-2
uh uh
oh no there you go
downfall
all over again yeah yeah you know what's
up
man natural is just going full flesh
offense right now winter bear can't even
get anything started
oh the laser laser scraper and still
finds the input the 4-4 at the end yeah
that looked a little hard for winter
bear right there actually that looked
like winter bear couldn't get anything
started
oh yeah that's that's i think these like
little formula is to just
start off with pressure get his
information and if he's not giving him
anything that's going to make him change
keep doing it until you know it puts to
all the owners on the other guy to adapt
so if that happens he's gonna keep
steamrolling
[Music]
well uh also just throwing the parries
in there naturally throwing the parries
in there that's a lot of uh dissuading
that you can do just with one oh yeah
and on top of that it catches
heisenberg's uh julia has a lot of moves
that all it takes is a 2-4 you could get
the knock down from jen and that gets to
start the game and offense has been the
name of the game anyways for natural so
it started the game off for electric got
good corner carry ain't even doing the
high wall splat combo uh with the mental
alertness that shuffle hand stance i
like what i'm saying here from natural
oh yeah yeah
yeah that's that's okay there you go
let's see um
what he's going to choose for adaptation
because i don't know much about winter
bears kit so he's going to stick to the
character kuni mitsu there you go
infinite stage interesting
oh wow yeah that small hitbox for uh
cooney i feel like it's one of those
things that her movement really kind of
accents man i love these three oh
there's these 3d tours of the stage that
they give us now before we actually go
into the game yeah this is clean yo
what's up i definitely found out a lot
of new uh
found out a lot of new
angles on this stage stuff like i'm
picking up details that i've never seen
before because they're giving us the 3d
stage especially the infinite stage
right where you can't really get near it
so if you see it from a different camera
angle okay
it needs to be careful i like the two
ones still keeping it uh real honest
right now yeah yeah fishing with that
down for two hours
we didn't get the car
honest commentators
there you go
keeping him in shift yeah oh quick stats
though
just tapping the leg
[Music]
oh denied
round two
bam okay disrespect a little a little
electric
all right
it's oh wow the one two three
there you go
yeah gets it back to one savage sword to
close it out dang goes for the slide
safe
offense for natural looking still about
the same that we saw from that first
game yeah
and and i like went to bed checking with
these down four one
four four two oh that rage made it take
off a chunk
i was hoping i was you know expecting
him to like get finished his dinner but
nah no good
let's see if winter break can get on the
scoreboard right now
it's due to brown inbound
okay i like winterberry
going for that
fishing with the lowe's right now no
break there you go beautiful
this could be his chance
oh
ready for the combo though
has
oh
okay question mark okay there he is
a little bit of a you know mind game
going on
okay it's a float
conversion in route well i'm not sure
what that was going for maybe guaranteed
damage uses the counter
no i have spacing on that
down back four
four four three almost finds his mark
manuel bears slowly but surely
oh wow let's see if that's a rock oh
yeah
and went to bear with the switch to kuni
mitsu not gonna help him out
yeah he gave him a little bit of extra
but it wasn't enough to cut the cake
but yeah look
uh natural is someone that we're gonna
expect to keep pushing this to the end
so
um you know not not surprised but at the
same time not bad from uh winter bears
well to get all the way down here um but
unfortunately he's eliminated right
these are loser side matches well it was
a good run
yeah yeah yeah we're doing the loser
side matches
let me go back let me go to the proper
pool age then to make sure i see that we
got like our first four people for that
uh that top eight so let me try to find
out so natural actually qualifies on the
loser side of top eight now with that
victory yeah yeah yeah
let me go check the recipe the end of
this the recipe is pretty good
so that was let's see
so we have
oh wow so we have six weeb ticks
six meatballs weight bits weight [ __ ]
thanks always do that we fixed uh going
up against browser and and these two
that's what we're gonna find i was gonna
make it to the top side of this uh well
the loser side of this top eight and
that's coming out of pool four
yes
oh
yeah
let's see who's coming that's right
three so
we've got for six wheat becks he's a
south australian player he's been doing
a lot of good stuff this year
um he's been a bit up and down he's been
making top top uh
top eight placements consistently he did
one he did win the couch warriors league
for june so he's got that on his resume
and even like in the uh the oceanic
tekken league ranking battle number two
that happened a few days ago he did
manage to hit uh fourth place but he's
doing really good but of course
he's versing like oh we got a different
match okay we're doing subjects versus a
friendly tree
very clever okay
yeah yeah yeah so a friendly tree
melbourne player legend nina main and
subject this is my okay you want my bias
vote for this tournament i want
something to do well south australian
player dragon off main the last one
alongside me we gotta keep we're gonna
stick together we gotta stick together
wow
okay the dragon propaganda huh
hey plans have changed okay we're gonna
adapt oh that's a low priority that i
didn't expect
oh wow butterfly
nice combo adjustment there too didn't
get the floor break though
um oh nice
yeah just when you like got low health
and you're all you're thinking about is
holding back they get you with the grab
good strap
okay checking in one down two it's
running through check
well i like the fish there you go you
know just in case one of those lows come
out yep
and it's safe minus nine
okay counter hit this time there you go
subject really fishing bound that's it
get the wall balance that's it
yeah i thought that was going to drop
out i thought that was actually going to
drop i was a little bit risky that was a
little bit risky you should have done
down back 202 or something i don't know
oh down four one four nice
okay get the combo we're gonna get the
wall for sure
right right they're not right if they
don't look if they're not defending
against they might as well
oh speaking of combo video the delayed
hopkins
no good okay valiant effort valiant
effort
let's see if he can bring it up back
friendly chinese to closes off
oh down two those man those down twos
are adding up like crazy
oh yeah
break on the one plus two never
underestimate the power of uh chip
damage man
break again look at that
oh big damage ain't got a back turned on
top of it
spins
and they go friendly tree taking the
first match
look man these two players are on the
top of their game did you see the like
the the nina combos how on point they
were like this guy's been playing this
character for years damn
i can't see you right now
nina as a character on almost any stage
i feel like she excels like she's always
gonna get like long combos and i feel
like she always has high damage at her
disposal that's one of the things about
nina fighting
and i always say this no matter how many
times because every time i see it i
think people forget it nina will blow
you up in a bracket and you said
we've been saying this this person
a neighborhood tree they've been playing
a friendly tree excuse me has been
playing nina for years and you could
tell just from the moment alone
yeah it's like the the more the better
the nina player the bigger the blender
it's like this it just gets worse and
worse and worse and as soon as you slip
up once it's just compound damage upon
damage it's not good
but you know subject you know he's
probably got the jitters he's kind of a
new guy like he's just doing really good
okay you know he's been winning things
here and there like he's one of those
south australian like you know up and
comers that everyone's really enjoying
i'm really enjoying as well
so seeing him and hey look man he's
playing dragon off okay that's enough
that's that's a that's a big cross to
bear that's all nowadays that's all you
need look first off they've definitely
made dragon off better so to stop that
uh oh yeah that definitely did i
definitely did but
i will say we definitely there's been a
shortage of uh dragging off players
there really has been it's it's
surprising because like this new update
they gave him a mad down too
and it's still like some people were
just like you know what nah i like my
new camera
yeah and i don't know who the loyalists
are
yeah
nice
nice side stepping to launch going to a
4-4
there we go
gets the flip
but the advantage not anymore
yo subject turning on the offense right
now looking a lot better
goes for the power crush against the
wall i like the option breaks the
multi-throw on top of it
going for a swipe of room
oh no break on the board you got to be
ready man and friendly tree is
definitely keeping you on your toes with
the multi-throat oh that's bars keeping
you on your toes with the multi throws
let's go
oh
big big
okay i like subject turning up this
offense right now
yeah almost gave him the justin wong
almost gave it to him
there we go keep it going oh wow oh that
one don't fall for that
this is dangerous
okay
okay
match point right now for friendly tree
fight
some panel banner oh what a sidewalk
nice that was clean
a 4-3 right there
out a lot more yeah slowing down this
game throwing this game down a little
bit
more down twos trying to go for the
perry the running two not gonna say
anything about it beautiful one two one
that's it
that's it slow down kid that's all you
need it's beautiful
oh whoa
i love this pace a friendly tree
starting to get a little more aggressive
yes
oh power questions beautiful completely
available
ready for that
break on a one plus two
a four four not gonna find this mark
subject trying to come back alive in the
second game oh the downfall
baby wait a minute
this is a complete change of pace right
now very nice adaptation subject
oh massive counter hit right there let's
see if you can get to the wall
oh oh my god
oh yeah
there you go oh doesn't get the pickup
oh gets the trade this is not looking
good for the subject goes for the low
and try
step a little too early the down four
one's gonna claim another victim
yeah it goes like that sometime
oh my god i'm sad because this is like
an elimination match okay well subject
did make it pretty deep in this
tournament friendly tree doing what he
does kicking ass so no surprise to be
honest this is going to be all heavy
hitters from this point on so like every
loss that i see feels like a
disappointment but it's like what else
can happen one guy has to go every time
from this point on it's just going to be
heartbreaking for a heartbreak
i think
that's why i say they're going through
the living room they're putting on their
pants and then they're going in the
living room to finish watching the
stream that's exactly what happens
that's right we're not playing in person
anymore you're playing in the comfort of
your own home you're going to finish the
rest of the tournament if you get
knocked out in the living room but yeah
like you said it's still opportunities
left in the top eight yeah and a
friendly tree now getting one of those
last remaining spots in the top eight i
think that means we only have what two
more left
if i think two more yes i mean and that
was out of those four pools
yeah yeah
oh there's more events coming up
yeah don't forget to sign up i think
we've got maybe roughly a week to go
till um the cutout period happens in
japan
online masters regional finals events oh
wow look how many regions man way more
than last year from the looks of it
no that's one of the best things about
this this tekken online challenge if you
want your tournament in your local
region to get in and be counted among
these dojos you have to october 10th
october 10th is the cut off that way you
can get your own local event signed up
for the dojo and make sure you can sign
up through this portal if you want to
play it in yourself for your respective
regions the tekken esports dojo tekken
dash esports dot b and dash ent.net
forward slash if you would like to be
involved playing these tournaments in
your respective regions submissions will
end october 8th so make sure you sign up
asap and like i said before october 10th
if you want your event in your region to
count and potentially be on that dojo
docket but points are always on the line
that way and a lot of regions are
getting a lot of players to sign up now
which means these are dojo events these
are points on the board for anybody in
their respective reasons
yeah yeah it's like there's there's no
reason not to sign off like that's
unless you're like i'm running on wi-fi
get an ethernet right now exactly makes
you laugh so much better
look
make sure if you sign up for these
tournaments a lot of times and i know
the tournaments out there that say hey
man we require like wired uh connections
and it's for good reason because we want
these connections to be as clean as
possible especially if you're playing
like a neighbor in your respective
regions so hey like my man said get an
ethernet cable bro
yeah yeah trust like dude if you can't
put a donation goal in your stream i'll
pay for it dude it doesn't matter it's
easy all right
and also like he's just yeah you're
courteous to your opponent as well not
just to yourself
it is what it is think about but yeah
man
yeah
um yourself we got two more battles
coming up
oh come on
so let's see though who got um bracket
hey let's see if we okay so there's neil
versus scorpion that has not been has
not played and let me just find the last
one and six we fix wowzer we're gonna
get one of those two right now so
neil is a uh
high level legacy multi-year probably a
decade long
uh even more who knows um hwarang maine
from new zealand really top bloke he
came here uh you know he was there at um
bam last bam you were here he was a evo
as well he came with one of the new
zealand crew and he'll be voting
scorpion one another legacy veteran
queensland uh player
it's gonna be a battle of the ages right
now so we're gonna have some veteran
veteran play
but scorpion is like a human raster kind
of guy where he just picks whatever he's
in the mood i can't tell you where he's
gonna play he's gonna pick something
that's a mystery huh
yeah oh look if he wants to
if you want to like blow through the
brackets sometimes you got to pull out
king i'll say that much you know there's
there's some good like blow up uh
capacity that when you pick king yeah
that would be a good pick he might be
kazuya he might be full might pick the
bears he's also a bear man he's doing a
lot of bad play
yeah and he's a bear man that's crazy
like and a bear man oh yeah king cosby
and the bear man wow
really yeah exactly
so yeah well we don't know what we get
yeah yeah going
no i was gonna say so it's gonna be neil
versus scorpion two guys who have a lot
of history uh in their respective
regions but my man has so many
characters that he could potentially
pull out i'm kind of interested to see
who we're gonna get is it a match-up
thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah usually we make a chat like
you know make a prediction for us or
something and i was like oh who's it
going to be and you know everyone just
starts chipping in and then it's like
none of that
oh yeah well so typically what happens
is we wait till we get to the top eight
i believe and then they start doing the
predictions to see if you know the chat
oh yeah actually paying attention to you
know some of the results oh yeah you can
make educated guesses about who's gonna
be involved in some of these matches and
who's gonna win i actually really like
that turns up the engagement as well as
i like to see who knows they're taking
while they're watching some of these
matches speaking of we're going to the
next one
let's see which one it is and we can get
into the weeds
i think it was nice
there we go
scorpion guaranteed there's the king
there's the the horang so triple s plus
dude this guy is a monster what do you
keep an eye out he's optimal what a
he's that annoying cousin that your
parents say but you know neil got s plus
on everything what are you doing neil
did fine in school
yeah yeah yeah
he has like two jobs
he calls his parents every day and he
has s plus on his rank okay
comes home on time looks like the type
oh okay oh yeah
i like the poke game coming from
scorpion with the king oh delayed
getting greedy already
here we are
shining wizards broken
these guys got their legacy reflexes on
their break windows they don't care
i mean that's crazy all right let's get
some people playing online
to get the clothes out okay
oh that was tight margin he got it
yeah while standing two two catching
neal over extending a little bit but now
neal going a lot more to the duck
i like starting off with the one two
string with walron too
back
definitely
back one not fine yeah look at scorpions
trying to get those grabs in he's trying
to force the the moment but it's not
happening
oh giant there it is
not going to get the wall but i think
scorpion knows that neil is not breaking
throws full crouch down 4-2
oh no not not aware of the wall giant
swing too the gorilla press slam is not
looking good oh my god yeah it's tough
oh but horan can bring it back if it's
anyone he can do it
break the oneplus 2 just a bit
just a bit outside
oh wave dash okay wait a minute scorpion
he's warming up he's warming up
yo
that's the blue stuff
again he's trying to get those grabs in
he'll sweep once again i like this
try the one two
and you can see right now scorpion being
trying to just counter punch a lot fish
for counting hits up close so that
pressure won't start oh my god caught
you ducking with the blue stuff
okay scorpion knowing how to break these
throws fishing with the downforce is
just a down one yeah
oh [ __ ]
yeah so that that disruptor with the
crouch jab was just it was news coming
in and that's all it took
damn
so even though i found scorpion was
overextending himself a little bit
trying to like force those grabs and
making him whiff
it didn't really matter at the end like
he wasn't like neil wasn't taking
advantage of those openings
and it was just like non-stop pressure
there's one grab and all that like 20
seconds of effort of like poking and
parting
it catches up straight away so it's just
that's the king game
yeah it's it's really tricky in this
matchup right it's kind of scary because
even though you have like the kick
counter you i feel like if you're wrong
you're looking for that you're thinking
about that especially if they have the
lead and they're looking for actual
throws uh and if i'm and if i'm king
i'm a king player if you don't break
giant swing i'm always gonna go for it
like and if my back is to the wall i'm a
hundred percent going forward because
that means i'm always gonna get the wall
so now you got to hope you don't go back
to the same stage if you got to worry
about going to a wallet stage in some
instances or just being a lot more
active on the throw breaker
yeah it's just it's a tough matchup
people like to cry about it but it's
legitimately not that unfair as you
think it is king is legit tough
character to like really succeed with
because like he's a scrub killer but
once you pass this threshold of like
high level play
yeah everything starts to level out
everything levels out so like you know
yeah it's a legit hard character
no that's absolutely there you go
because you start to understand my game
a little bit more oh precipitation yeah
this is not a good draw and he picked
and then he picked this statement as
well so that's a strange thing so maybe
just has like maybe has optimized combos
get hit anywhere taking you to the wall
rong has a pretty decent wall carry as
well especially if you get the proper
hits and you know the strings but here
we go yeah
wow shining where they're like running
with the stage
yeah horn has become like a bowl of
thorns ah there you go
i told you i'm not stopping if you if
you're not breaking it at least he gets
the tech though gets a little less
damage full crouch down three
coming for huaran
okay break the china
oh
yo these
now the stances are starting to work out
that flamingo yeah
puts them in early rage right now
scorpion in trouble
and just to see we have to close out
and a lot slower than we've seen these
other games go i started with the throw
breaks and that was kind of like
devolving
oh no break on the one plus two
wow just backing out of that range
nice
you didn't see that every day you
definitely oh there you go catch them
out of here
takes the oaky tries to make him stand
up
locks us the stomp oh man this is gonna
be a chunk of damage
look at this his giant swing right is
insane oh no break on the muscle buster
either this is not looking good neal
needs to do that you know
oh
like i said i'm not stopping yep
no breaks no oh no attack
there you go
you're gonna build something
there you go go to bro
okay okay
that's exactly what you want
wow and he just keeps ducking
but he got lucky though because the
backer it made him turn up back turn so
the combo wasn't gonna hit all the way
all right neal still alive in it yup
chance for redemption
all a good quarant needs is two combos
that's it you know it's like you
creating those opportunities
the thing is is that scorpio has a good
understanding of when to like kind of
duck jab interrupt a lot of these
strings so it's making neal go for a lot
more pokes bad punish right there okay
break the giant swing very good break
out
yeah yeah it definitely broke like a
full full grabs right there nice
catching the backlash there you go
oh yeah
big damage let's see wristband scaling
back three
bad idea
bad idea
as a king player i can tell you right
now
it's hard not to go for that move it's a
special get up you don't have sometimes
you don't have to worry about people
floating you because it's so strange but
if they really uh and on top of that
wall wrong has back three has so much
range it's an instant launch if you have
a back turn combo it's always going to
work out so i like that you had the
advantage got the knock down and just
waited for him to do something bad which
so happened to be that spring kick and
not the right thing to do
now i wonder if there's going to be a
momentum shift now where maybe neil's
kind of like you know
warmed up he's he ate all the grabs that
he got him out of his system all the no
breaks
now he's going to be breaking now he's
going to be applying a little bit more
gas
and see if he can just because the thing
is that like huarang is that throttle
machine non-stop you know fire so he's
got to like you know rev it up a bit
but then again when he pulled back that
also gave him a lot of more
opportunities to just get that jab in
and then like continue into something
with
more significant pressure instead of
just taking turns you know back and
forth block attack block attack block
attack that becomes a little bit loopy
if you saw what neil was uh looking for
the fact is is that if you don't check
warong while he's doing like stance
changes those down jabs they seem
miniscule right they don't seem like
they're going to do a lot but it's
important yeah yeah you can answer that
wrong if he's if he's in flamingo a lot
of times you need to be careful that's
right the scorpion for the one two he's
looking for that one two startup and
then he knows if he goes up the stairs
then he can he can interrupt him which
is the smart thing to do you're playing
a little further back but just like you
said the meta is going to change now
because now the throw breaks are coming
out and neil has something to look
forward to and scorpion ducking early on
both of these guys duncan early in the
round here
nice there you go
he's just gonna try it again see if it
works for him and it's doing wonders and
now he's going deeper in that multi bag
oh boy are we are we crossing the bridge
i think so break his back oh god ah
god look at that okay he has to be oh no
i'll say he's got to be real slick to
stay alive for this but so tough
yeah the okie after most balti throws
it's not in your favor so you got to be
careful oh yeah oh the alley kicks
almost got the wall giant swing he
breaks this time neal's awake oh if he
would have let that rip he would have
actually got the launch
yeah yeah yeah
damn okay okay back and off try again
try again there we go
weird angle to catch the wall real early
but uh let's see if we can maintain his
wall pressure
but look at this this is it
office coming from war on oh no break on
the muscle bus you're going to be closer
never mind you're dead oh my god that
took off a lot i didn't i didn't think
that was going to kill
yeah it caught him holding back a bit
too much just out of that pressure of
low health makes you just really like
stiff in the air in the defense
right see like right there you have to
interrupt hualong you have to interrupt
war on when he does like the scissor
kick
there you go
playing back a little bit that down back
three
one two one gold's trying to go for the
hanging vertical suplex another muscle
buster see now scorpion knows he's
having trouble breaking throws and he's
gonna keep abusing another one goes for
the duck no break on the normal throw
away
okay okay okay
factory okay there's the low
thing okay
still alive but still alive let's see
this might go to final final round
see and now you see that he's reacting
to the down jab and he did hunting hawk
right there which would have gave him a
launch there's a hop kick he's a little
far out not gonna get the tailspin i'm a
king player i can see that happening a
mile away i
that that shining wizard is definitely
not the will to keep going to now neil's
breaking giant swing and breaking a
shining wizard one two three yeah there
it is there's a break again
looking for the down four two you gotta
break this you do not want to pay the
total across that bridge okay goes to
the stl no no he goes for the stf he's
still alive
down back three blocks it down four and
down four one to interrupt the pressure
that's exactly what i was talking about
though if you see if you see while on do
scissor kick you have to interrupt them
and this time not even going for a safer
instance just goes for down four one
caught him trying to do a move and
that's absolutely gonna do it nice
playing though and if i'm not mistaken
that is loser's side so that means neil
is gonna be going home going to the
living room i would like to say uh
not gonna be it's still a good showing
though right outside that top eight um
still has an opportunity later on
because there are more events but
unfortunately that's gonna be the end of
the road for neal
yeah man it was a good run but damn man
it's tough as we said heartbreak it's
gonna be heartbreak highway right now
everything we do is it's gonna be
off and the next one's coming up is
gonna be very interesting as well
because we're going to have six big six
wheat picks versus wowza six week picks
has been a south australian like regular
um always turning up for many many
tournaments doing well for himself
but wowzer is probably known as one of
the top or the top if you want to like
really debate between him and natural
maybe oh being the top new zealand
player so he also flew to evo he came to
bam
he usually
like he usually wins wherever he goes he
takes it you know what i'm saying okay
uh alyssa play he used to be an elisa
player
um until like the latest updates where
they kind of changed the her playstyle
they made her more aggression focused
and he's a very
he the thing is that this is very
strange almost strange but like uncommon
the wildest first second game has been
taken seven
and he came in a little bit let's say
like it's his first game is tekken 7
and already he's at the highest echelon
within like a couple years let's say a
year a year and a half
and his style of play is very
ultra totally very korean like if you
say a lot of back dashing a lot of
simple jabs but very defensive play so
once they change that with um alyssa's
play style to make a more chainsaw heavy
which is like benefiting more aggressive
players let's say like a cuddle where
she just loves that stuff she just digs
in
so wells has been moving to kuni mitsu
after that so when she came out he's
like okay new waifu you know this is my
new wife kuni mutsu but now i don't know
if he's going back and forth i don't
know because he
has been not appearing as much in uh
online tournaments he does his local
ones definitely
new zealand tournaments he loves to turn
up to those
but across ocean ones he's like ah maybe
maybe not but now he's here i was very i
was very happy to see you okay
he was one of the last sign-ups for
today i was like yes we've got wowza so
i'm looking forward to see how he's
going to play so this is a tough and i'm
actually surprised that he's in loser's
side
and i will say let's see who actually
knocked him
it's six week picks it's a rumble oh so
this is the run back this is a double
jump this is
so in the oceana region region is there
a lot of kunimitsu representation or is
it kind of like you got a handful of
them or maybe less than a handful
because i know we like in this in the
states we don't have that many but we've
got a few that's been popping up at the
icfc yeah we have very few i would say
yeah i would say like you may see one in
a tournament like you know it's not like
super all over the place or something
but whoever does is kind of good with
her if that makes sense like they kind
of spend that extra time to get it down
as a new character
so
yeah you'll see maybe two three four
tournaments okay
it will take it's not bad
well i know but yeah the score is
getting a lot more shine they're getting
a lot more shine with these different
characters especially if it actually is
the kuni mitsuba but what was the score
you were about to tell us a score
yeah so the score was 2-1 so it wasn't a
blowout in any sense so it was a back
and forth so this could totally flip
and
if i had to make a guess because six
week picks does play a couple characters
okay and if i can make a bet for today's
event that's really important i would
say he's gonna pull out the lydia
the lydia is his main like i would say
the one that he gets results with
that's gonna be a lot of fun because she
when she starts throwing gang signs it
gets all it gets pretty wild
yeah
so yeah
red tape i don't know what that means
miss prime minister she's just beating
the crap out of you
no but i do like the fact that we're
starting to see a lot more lydia uh that
season four uh update was very kind to
her um i know a lot of players uh
particularly arsenal and ash was saying
how well how much better the character
is well-rounded for uh a top eight
showing or just to keep people on their
toes solid tech and play really does uh
benefit a character like lydia because
if you're not punishing properly she has
a nice jab on top of just decent pokes
to keep you honest so i feel like if
you're not punishing a character like
lydia properly uh in a top eight where
you already have kind of like to play
against your nerves solid take and play
is really what that character excels at
and if you got a legacy skill player i
feel like they can really take advantage
of her stances uh political storm was
just ridiculous in all honesty i just
learned how to properly punish it if
they actually stop the string early
because the fight is 10 and not minus
12. so stuff like that is kind of the
knowledge check that you get versus this
character because a good lydia she's not
going to give you a lot of instances to
actually go for perry that's just how
good that she is you know
yeah yeah and i think that was like the
real key statement is with a combination
of legacy skills this character really
excels like i've seen it like dion gray
doesn't really play play her
but he's got that legacy skills and he
just like will toy with you toy with you
like with that character but he's like i
would say we're gonna see him later
today i would say he's going to pull the
leroy that's his main since release
he's really made the jump and that
character is also one of those where if
you know how to get into your opponent's
brain
that you're rent-free the whole time
it's really good
and and leroy if we do indeed to leroy
leroy plays a little different game uh
still has very good control of the up
close game but can really bait you
into you know making some really big
mistakes moves like shotgun really do
take advantage of that up close game
especially if you get somebody who
really likes to you know overextend a
bit too much orbital teaches a lot of
people a lesson and if you do get to
that up close game like simple tools
like down back three from leroy yeah
full crouch down 4-3 where they get to
annoy you a little bit sidestep but
there are tools that he has just to
annoy you enough to get you to swing up
close and fish for those big counter
hits so if we see the leroy yeah it's
really going to be telling about the
opponent especially if you know if we
see a lot of counter hits coming from
certain tools
oh yeah yeah you'll be you'll you'll
know how like
how dion enjoys the game when you see
him play leroy he like because i know
him personally whoever's met him knows
him kind of how he is
when he plays he's always like laughing
and smiling all the time he's just like
really enjoying himself so okay he's a
bit sadistic sometimes when he's really
getting in there he's like loving it
it's like you know it's kind of one of
those types i'm looking forward to like
manchester united
yeah yes yes yes yes 100
but it's like he really like the best
way to describe dion is that he knows
his situation
so he knows if he's plus minus he knows
if he's got an advantage or not
and he just plays with that back and
forth so it really makes it work let's
see okay let's see
what i think we're going to get you guys
i think we're going to dion gray and uh
yagami actually i think we're going
we're going to switch it up really
no no no no we got something okay we're
getting sick excuse me my bad my bad
we're actually going in okay okay let's
go and we actually do have a lisa
and the alyssa now this alyssa coming up
is huge i don't know like i'm like whoa
because he really is like staying away
from her but you know when things get
tough you kind of can't you know abandon
your original homie okay it's all about
that alyssa
we're getting in there okay and he's
picked his uh iconic favorite uh preset
tournament legal
i like that i like how you say
tournament illegals turn them illegal
nobody freak out oh yeah yeah
yeah because i think when um the presets
came out
um while i was posted on twitter like my
mom got angry that she saw me with that
with that custom
[Laughter]
should have told this tournament legal
right yo is tournament legal calm down
okay
oh nice conversion here and the wall
realignment i thought we were looking
for like a backpack right there
round two
but here we go
nice yeah
loves to
yeah so wilson really loves to use the
side dwarf
sidewalk game is very big with him and
no better character than using alyssa
for that kind of play stuff
yeah she's got a lot of good there you
go
just down 4-2 gets the launch
fights back to the middle of the stage
here
six weebs takes in trouble getting a lot
of pokes what a sidestep right goes for
the hive kicks
and gets the wall the wall for the last
ball down the combo
calculated baby calculator gold we
should kick the head or
that running one nice block full
partnership with the round rising too
not close enough to get the full combo
though
wow
there it is
so wowzer is moving a lot and you can
tell that yes
is actually paying attention to it oh
nice wow
you see that he's just got like an ultra
instinct man
oh tapping the legs
see the side step right wowzer goes for
the realignment gets the wall bounce
goes for the stop not the legs
oh
dude what a treat is to watch wowza play
alyssa i gotta say dude it's a treat
every time
damn so yeah you see like that sense of
that sidestepping he knows exactly when
to get out of it it's almost like uh
he's in practice mode where he's like
okay they do that i step i try my launch
do my combo it's almost that in tune
with the situation
so i'll find the watch on the wall
yeah i like that and you you called out
like the the sidewalks as well
especially coming from alisa she has a
lot of good tools typically that uh that
standing for a very good tool for
catching people like sidewalk but we've
been seeing like the dow four too right
and just committing to some ducks
sometimes getting that full crouch
punish and the launch so just playing it
a lot slower with elise and i feel like
that's what's really helping him out
yeah yeah yeah so i'm curious to see how
um six week picks is gonna adapt to this
because i would say look the strongest
character is lydia but maybe a stage
change will be what he needs i don't
know what he would personally want
to improve his position like what would
he need to do let's say
i guess because that sidestep game he's
got to be aware of it you know just like
fake it out block you know just like
actually you're gonna do something don't
do anything
try an eno take advantage of their
presuppositions
so i think that uh one of the things
that lydia has is that jab dude her jab
pushes her forward a little bit as well
as her hopkins and just the fact that
you can annoy kind of like dragon off
style pressure she kind of has that same
range but she has
running one that you have to like
respect that range so lydia has a lot of
tools to keep you honest up close her
down four one is good she has good
crouching punish to uh make sure that
even if you do see like a down four
coming from alisa even if you do see a
shoe shine uh lydia gets pretty decent
punish on that so it's more about
controlling the pace versus elise this
match is going fast i feel like alisa is
the victor but if it's going a little
slower pace it's more about the fact
that you know lydia is getting the
advantage
yeah and definitely to me has always
been a high tempo stage
every combo is like you know you can
just go full damage not to care about
carry because you will get the wall
it just promotes a lot of like uh
aggressive wild play
and there you go talking about gets a
4-2-4 with the punish and that's exactly
what i'm talking about the up close game
for like lydia she can still fight this
just the same oh tries the duck right
there
while rising one
quick ducks uh we biggs needs to be
careful i know wildzer is paying
attention to it now
and look sidestep still there the down
four twos
it needs to be careful both of these
guys realizing that they they like the
sidewalk going for a lot of track and
moves between them yeah yeah
look look nothing but tracking moves
right there using that fans
a little bit
down back three
going to the poke game and no combos at
the second round the second game
yeah another big trade i like that i
like that
low pair nice low parry that was clutch
yeah yeah
i should be able to get that should get
him to the wall
like i said before down two and another
two or when the scramble happens
typically you see elisa is the character
that you need to watch out for but i
think lydia has good tools for stopping
that approach up close while rising too
wow
actually caught the little sidewalk
right there
blue stuff on the wall
443 not gonna work out here's a chance
wowzer
and look there's that jab and the punish
okay
oh denied okay throwing signs
with the low this time getting the look
wow
that's insane so now he's taking the
lead of this match okay don't forget
this is a run back that wiles was trying
to like you know make right for what he
was wrong
and the bix needs to like you know
make sure that he can seal his fate and
just give him that double jeopardy
and look at this you see wowza going
back to the lows again now that mix-up
is starting to like come out is it going
to be the low is it going to be the mid
the running to the pool wow see and look
wild is starting to get the lead of this
again and we mix was looking like he was
making a comeback here in the second
game but now wowser with the elisa
down to lowell perry once again wows it
with the scout but drops the combo
okay the one once okay didn't i playing
a little bit of a koi match like okay
pulling back oh guess the wall spot
we fixed in trouble trying to go over
the leg cross up
catches the sidewalk with the one two
wow
i like that gets the tracking mid once
again and that's why you don't do it
like we
just kept trying to sidestep and really
got caught with the sidestep duck uh
guessing game and i like the fact that
you know lisa takes advantage of it she
has a lot of tracking moves especially
when it comes to those mids they're
really fast and a lot of times you're
looking for those lows so wheat bix
unfortunately not gonna be going any
further in the tournament
yeah the bix is out that's what like
brown man and i call him the bix
we're
but he hasn't changed the name we're
forcing it looks like one day you're
going to be the biggs okay we believe in
it but dude of course mad mad um you
know results top 16 or you know like
this really stacked out tournament like
you know like oh here we go let's see
the whole what's available
so we've got win a semi-final so we've
got dion graves yagami
then we got 500 milligrams of trend per
week versus extra mint this is a lot of
grand final material for the winter side
right there and now we've got scorpion
versus wowza that will be coming up and
then natural versus a friendly train
losers side
oh it's getting pretty intense for me oh
yeah
so we're getting a lot of representation
here in this top eight bro i'm liking
the the the character variety we've
gotten so far
yes oh i didn't mention anything i want
to see if you like bring it up like i
find that australian tournaments full
characters that i don't see in other
like i say north america or european
tournaments we kind of spread them out
nothing that you really expect we
haven't seen serious amount of machima's
yet nothing of the you know the common
varieties no akuma yeah thank god you
know stuff like that it's like we've got
you know we got lydia though that's
pretty cool because he didn't see much
lydia so i'm pretty hyped about that we
saw dragon off we got those they're
still around they went to australia
that's where they went so yeah
i'm curious like how you talk about
you're the only two dragon offs left in
the world it feels like we really
obviously you know
i know i do know we don't see many of
them these days so it's really not the
worst i mean especially with the dragon
offs but
i'm glad you guys are glad you are still
repping yeah yeah because like the
dragon believes we're getting what we
deserve because you know we remember
season one right like that was
not fun for everybody else great for
dragon of maine's but you know but as
soon as season 2 came in we found out
who the real dragon off mains are there
aren't that many of yous everyone else
bandwagon that's what was happening one
of the last results
look i know you got you really like
dragging off well there's a lot of
characters that you guys can kick check
out with these good ass tekken shirts if
you head on over to ten dash oh
slash merch you can get your very own
good ass tekken even if you can't play
it you can display it and we just got
those king shirts back in as well as the
law which all were limited and and you
can only get them for a limited time we
brought them back and of course we got
that cute ass ticket we got julia we got
leeroy we got the twins we got the kings
you can get them all if you head on over
to 10-0 check out the merch or you can
use this qr code you can get the paul
good ass tekken the a good ass taking
the long good ass second as well as that
cute ass taking that you can see right
there man handle head on over to 10-0
let them know that i sent you if you
want to look cool in some good ass
tekken
cute i was taking i never heard that one
you know like you know what i haven't
heard anything
none
she'd be taken no no
that's pretty good i got the leeroy
sugar that's pretty good yeah yeah i
have the lemon powder blue i think it's
powder blue maybe the sky blue
you know um but of course like i said
you guys can head on over to 10-0 if you
would like to get access to some of this
merch but if you would like to get
access to the news and everything
related to bandai namco as well as
tekken make sure you give us a follow on
twitter with b esports on twitter as
well as for the videos if you can't
catch the vibes head on over to youtube
b and e esports on youtube as well and
if you like tekken check it out on all
our socials whether it's twitter whether
it's twitch whether it's facebook make
sure you give us a follow to stay up to
date on everything tekken and that way
you can know when me and my boy go live
but we still gonna be live but we're
gonna take a quick commercial break
that's because this top 8 is coming on
the other side make sure you guys join
us we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bandit is downrange
arrive to
destination
enemy reinforcements check your radars
[Music]
[Music]
foxton
[Music]
i fought all types of fighters in my
time
but who knows what other crazy strong
guys are still out there
now to get stronger than ever before
i've had enough now i'm mad frieza i'm
not gonna lie it's tense times like
these that really get me pumped for a
[ __ ] honey
but what i do know is that i'd like to
avoid fighting if i can and just let him
go later you guys i hope you're reborn
as someone good this time
[Music]
i can't wait to find out
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
tekken online challenge for oceania 2021
powered by astro the official headset
and exam for the taken online challenge
damn we have finished our loser side
matches and now we're stuck in top eight
okay this is it the final final stretch
and i'm going to say before we get there
i just want to like
you know um you know tasty steve was
like i'm gonna get a red bull you know
what i'm gonna get a caprice right now i
can't help myself i need the sugar kick
but
yo steve you won't actually you know
what no you want one
no look you know typically i would i
know you have the ability to do this but
i'm watching my carbs i'm trying to get
back into prime shape i'm gonna say no
for this time around but ain't your boy
brown man around somewhere bro you know
he loves chicken snacks you're brown man
yep do you want the do you want the
capris got a damn tin of them
take the whole dude i got top eight just
take it take it
let's take the damn thing
okay cool
ever
yeah dude of course i'll take a pack of
team times dude just give that [ __ ]
there you go
yeah no what what has anybody been
talking [ __ ] about the tim tams
everyone's been saying like
misinformation campaigns i've been
hearing over north america but somebody
told saying some bad things about them
tim tams
brown
brown man definitely almost killed rip
bro because i don't know why he told him
to eat an entire pack of tim tams he
offered me something
but i was like yeah he said have some he
can have one but not one packet i'm just
gonna put it for later i'm just gonna
enjoy myself
gotta give him strength
in one sitting
a thin layer see you guys have to have
construction they need to put that on
the top of the lid or something bro my
man rip probably ate
a vegemite
not one
it's 11 servings not one
bro isn't that in australia you can't
rip can't read that
okay it's still 11. even if it's upside
down
yeah okay so we're coming up
those are mad matches coming up so
let us get into uh our sponsorship we're
going to say shout outs to astro for
being the official headquarters and mix
up here for the tekken online challenge
uh they've been holding down the
fighting game community for quite some
time they've been hooking up all the
commentators with these a40 headsets
especially uh coming from like evo
earlier so shout outs to astro for
holding us down shout outs to astro for
actually supporting tekken and
continuing to do this yeah the patron
saints of the tekken fgc dude patron
saints
there you go they're keeping us alive
dude that's alive
but yeah so we saw the brackets we're
going to check them out right now so as
we said win aside we've got genuine
gaming's dion gray we've got dht's
yagami we've got 500 milligrams trend
per week and extra mint okay super heavy
hitting top of winner side and a loser
side we got um scorpion
we've got wowzer natural and a friendly
tree everything beyond this point is
going to be grand final material so get
ready for like you know a double duty of
you know top level play from the oceanic
region so first match win aside genuine
gaming's dion gray versus dht's yagami
gonna be good this is um
dion gray uh sydney player um he used to
live in melbourne sir and he used to
live in new zealand so he's got he's a
mr worldwide he's our pitbull okay so
he's been around okay but
we own him okay he's sydney now and of
course we've got yagami which is from
victoria which is melbourne the other
you know okay major city in australia
so yeah shout out to melbourne i miss
being in melbourne bro that was the last
place when i was over there i was in
melbourne australia it was a good time
it was a good time
yeah yeah that stuff it'll come back
you'll come back
don't worry
but yeah we had a big um turn up i've
got like this that got my sheets in my
fact we've got 22 players that came from
victoria and 26 players that came from
new south wales new south wales is the
state that what i'm sydney is in and
newcastle uh wollongong all those kind
of major cities
okay yeah um yeah yeah so new south
wales had the biggest turn up of 26.
before we had 22. queensland had 11.
south australia had seven
and then you got a ct which is the
australian capital territory it's like
you know like uh what was it in in
america right where new york and los
angeles was supposed to be like the
capital cities but they gave him to dc
so they weren't so they wouldn't buy it
same thing in australia sydney and
melbourne were fighting give it to to
canberra where's canberra i don't know
but there's nobody no that's the trick
they can't be exactly that's how they
keep it
[Music]
all right here we go
that leroy let's see if what i said
comes to pass because i can tell you
right now that up close that up close
game from leroy is not as easy to take
advantage of
from alisa because he has so many good
tools but let's see and this stage is
mad small too
let's see if we can get these
predictions started for top eight man
but yo chat let me let me know who you
guys are going for let me know who you
guys are going for
dude we got dion gray or we got yagami
who you guys cheering for what a big
launcher coming from your gummy already
though
this is a strong start for himself 50
health lead right now from the get-go
make that 80 health lead
oh what a block on the down back three
this is a very strong startup from
yagami no joke
let's see if he can maintain this there
you go he's warming up the old beetles
are coming out
it sticks into the wall
gets a nice wall pressure what's the
wake up there it is now there's the
factory yeah
back to the wheel that's right down back
forward didn't work out goes for the low
chainsaws oh usually invasion gets the
wall bounce and the rage on deck two so
that means this is definitely doable and
the orbital like i said before
yes exactly shutting him down
let's say one a pace now
[Music]
damn this hammerhead thing just hit so
hard oh yeah
apart from like that random scream in
the air that you get sometimes and you
freak out the tap the train
in the world of tech and i never thought
i'd see the day
i know i
yo
i was thinking literally the same thing
while standing too uh uh
oh nice it's a carry right there with
that
that hermit stands extended oh bounce
gives him the
needs to knife careful though
there's nobody
i got my own
not big daddy kane's out getting a full
oh no he dropped the combo
down four one there it is
i'm surprised we haven't seen much
shotgun counter hit
on the second hit of that four four yeah
he might just keep that in the pocket
for later why don't we throw all these
uh choices right now that he's got the
advantage
right now
your gummy backing up down back oh dude
it's up the street oh my god
wow
dude yagami's popping off right now dude
and dion gray
he needs to get into gear right now
that was that was left to the wire it's
like too uncomfortable how close that
match was wow that was good but from
both sides
lots of swinging coming from both of
them in all honesty i like the offense
coming from elisa though towards the end
there i was expecting but i'm gonna tell
you right now i'm gonna tell you right
now i was expecting a little more
offensive retaliation coming from leroy
we didn't we only saw one orbital i
thought that was going to be the
beginning of it because that's what i'm
looking for i'm looking for the shotguns
i'm looking for the wildstanding twos
i'm looking for the four two twos though
those are the tools that leroy likes to
use up close to keep people honest even
an elisa who seems a little bit
overwhelmed she seems like she can
overwhelm you pretty easy with the
chainsaw pressure we saw the side step
uh come in with the automatic evasion
and got the wall belts i'm thinking that
we're going to see that get slowed down
to a pace where it's going to be
controllable but it's not because we're
not seeing any challenges coming from
leroy so that's what we need to see
that's one of the things that needs to
change because they were just swinging
at each other and elisa definitely she
knows how to function in the scramble
yeah yeah definitely and i i usually
find that dion's playstyle is a little
bit more aggressive like what you were
kind of expecting i was expecting as
well
he's usually just poking you and has
that one poke advantage on top of you
he's like always one like almost one
frame ahead so you can't really go for
it at any time that's how he likes to
play he likes to be in your head
but um he definitely has several
characters they may fall back to just in
case he doesn't he feels off like i
remember back in season three days
um a very common thing that dion would
say like he backed this was season two
when he was traveling and you know world
tours and all that used to be playing
geese back then right right
playing
yeah so he was playing geese but he
would say if i'm in tournament and all
of a sudden i'm not executing right i'm
just feeling off it could happen between
matches not necessarily you have a bad
day but you just might have a bad match
you'll fall back to other characters
like for example jack that's his
original season one character but the
fact that he stuck with leroy means that
he he knows that he can get the job done
and he's not feeling off just a matter
of approach at this point
let's see how he's going to play it out
and there is no orbital there is the
orbital this is exactly what i was
talking about oh big damage here ah
orbital of skin like i said resetting
the scaling dude another one
counting
i like this i like this borderline
perfect borderline perfect there you go
the back four didn't find his mark
you got me trying to slow it down a
little bit goes back to the folks tries
the early side step good block and what
did i say
once we started seeing the shotguns this
is how leroy controls a neutral game
even versus a character like elisa the
back four catches him trying to sidestep
there's a down back three against the
wall okay look at this
he's in the gear right now
and this is when you want to see elisa
start playing that that play play back a
little bit what you got me is doing
beyond turning up the defense though
down back four is one of the main tools
using to open up the game
down four four no in the hermit stands
and just your gummy just playing back
not trying to mess with it get the
counter hit back four
uh uh oh i like the combo extension to
the wall look at the damage oh my god
yeah welcome to dion land this is it
the big triple no d9 okay cool cool
pencils are out
oh i like this advantage
with the blue stuff if you got them in
the chat i know we got some taste buds
in the chat and we got taste buds chat
let me see your blue stuff i know you
got them blue stuff right now
and this these hermit mix-ups are really
starting to get the best of you got me
right now dion gray just holding hermit
stands oh yeah
up whiffs good ah don't ever extend like
that
be very dangerous
okay so it looks like yagami's trying to
like with a side step he's trying to
create an opportunity oh no ahead today
boy get out of here no thanks no thanks
[Music]
hold the low parry
get down away again that race drive
and that's gonna be enough yagami can
still steal this set dion grey was
looking like a game was coming but off
oh big daddy kane denied
big chainsaws
okay good block
nice with the low parry
okay let you get him to the wall let's
see how he's going to fold this up he's
going to make any pressure oh there you
go
very nice
there it is recent scaling
on
great
dion gray holds the hermit stance to let
you know it wasn't a fluke we got one
more game in the set but that's exactly
what i was looking forward to come to
for this set we was talking about what
needed to be done for leroy to get back
control right and what exactly what i
was thinking i'm like look if we start
seeing shotguns even alisa is gonna have
to back up a little bit those orbitals
in that first round second game really
set the pace we got like two rounds
instantly just by using orbital against
the wall
yeah yeah it's like it makes you
second-guess yourself especially the
shotguns where you think okay now it now
now boom and you're over it's over it's
like oh they're playing yoshimitsu like
when you think that like okay these are
my opportunities these are my responses
well that's what they're waiting for
it's like where i'm develop this
instinct to just pop you for every time
you think that you got the advantage
so yeah as you said it just pretty much
played out as you predicted and
it's going to be interesting to see how
yagami is going to respond to that
because even in this match it was almost
over he almost took that so he's not
that far off from the answer if that
makes sense is this going to create more
opportunities for himself yeah yeah
it's it's more about it's looking at the
what we're seeing here
you can you can answer back like you
said um they definitely made it so
alyssa can be a lot more
she could be a lot more aggressive in
the neutral now even versus some of
these characters you got to play back a
little bit and respect the range of a
lydia of a leroy even like a falcon ram
is one of those characters that she has
to like play back a little bit but it's
still there she can definitely turn on
the offense we saw it a little bit with
the chainsaw pressure because dion was
not reacting the right way in a lot of
instances and even if it wasn't big
damage or a combo that came from it just
the lows that we see come from that
hermit stand come from chainsaw stands
really does add up
hmm
let's see if the infinite stage is going
to make that difference
there's one thing that um leroy is good
at is gap closing like he can have a big
distance from you but he'll just like
shut you off with a big whiff punish
and
and elise's movement uh on a stage like
this can really take her apart
especially with the side steps that's
exactly what i was talking about not
having to worry about some of that wall
pressure that leroy is going to be able
to get coming from these big counties
like shotgun
oh special
you got to respect the space and no tech
there means you're gonna get the
follow-up what about
i didn't see the follow-up coming i like
the choice from yagami though
yeah that was good that was good
okay so yagami's got the lead now
it's two rounds that's all he needs
down jab backed up a little bit you got
me going to that chainsaw stance this is
exactly what i was talking about you can
see your gummy playing back at like that
range to range three and the side steps
adding up too
oh yeah
there we go
maintaining pressure going mid
you can force some sort of counter hit
out of them
down four okay that's why yeah this
challenges him right once he goes into
stance just to immediately challenge it
no good break
yeah break on the normal throw
okay
okay
that's how you know yagami is awake
blocks both hits didn't even take the
punishers like i just want you to know
that i'm in your head right now yeah i
ain't just randomly blocking
okay oh it's anyone nice response five
seconds
wow
okay
in this third game two rounds on set
point here
winner semis
still best of three
oh orbital
oh yo the hit on the race drop
okay
on kid okay this is very good scenario
for yagami right now
he's gonna tank it no no no
no ralph brown
knocked out the flushed yagami
pushing himself right through winner's
side
unreal
unreal
that was crazy go to the loser's side
gonna go down on the lower bracket side
of things because that was definitely
winners uh damn three rounds to none no
yo
that is
that's tough that's tough juice as they
say and i you know i'm my boy for this
is gonna be like deon grey right so
seeing him get knocked down so quickly
is gonna be like upset city right now so
it's very very interesting finals we're
going to have this is going to be really
fun to watch because the the upcoming
match that we're going to have i'm
assuming is going to be 500 milligrams
of trend per week versus extra minutes
yeah so that is going to be a very
interesting match because
okay how do we narrow this down they're
both from melbourne they um 500 mils
he is like the always the runner-up if
that makes sense like he's always trying
to he'll get the reset on the grand
final but he can't close it he's always
trying to get it he got a couple of
first placements never the bride huh
yeah man he's like on that point right
he's on the precipice all the time
so and then we've got extra who
has been winning a couple of uh
tournaments here and there from the
previous dojo events so let's see how
it's going to play out this time because
i don't know if i've seen them in the
same at the same place at the same time
if that makes sense this is going to be
interesting to see how it's going to
play out there a grand final we never
had that we wanted to see if that makes
sense
so it's going to be a lot of fun to see
how it's gonna play out
you know that tends to happens a lot of
time ever since we started like the
online tournaments i've been watching a
lot of more different regions and
they're still players that you typically
sometimes don't get to see match up
against each other and it only happens
in these taking online challenges on on
these tekken dojos or some of these
tekken masters once again why
highlighting the scene especially for
specific regions is so powerful it makes
it so you get to see all these different
players from these different regions
that you typically don't get to see so
more of it i like this i like the way
this is set up and we already showed you
guys all the dates that you could
potentially check out in all your
objective regions uh there's a lot of
dates coming up and i believe that
deadline to sign up and make any one of
these upcoming events uh a dojo event is
the tenth so please don't forget but
here we go
there and in the previous bettings every
eighty-one percent of people were
betting for dion gray
the yagami guys are popping off then
there we go okay
so
uh
500 mils always mix up he's got he's
running he's changing names every week
so 500 mils of trend dropping the lars
that is his true main for the past year
or so performing really well with him
and extroverts going full on with his uh
xiaoyu which is like his strongest pick
by far
all right yeah we getting a lot of
character variety so far i guess the
shoulder the clothes oh yeah
turn low
running three uses the aop
i love the down fours coming from lars
the down back four as well make sure you
use those lows to keep laying on it
because she can definitely start to get
annoying if you let that back turn fans
rock you let aop rock those lows are
going to be your only the only way to
stop what a whip punisher again and very
nice wall but no
nice wall splat that should finish it
once he gets the yeah oh no there it is
it's that five hp man it makes the
difference it's the whole radical bro
everybody got to eat
it was like check your life bottom line
you're gonna have an extra five points
you mean i can lift that wall break
combo yes it's because harada came
that's right
so now you guys gotta thank harada you
know there's some people out there gonna
be like hey harada i don't like the fact
that i gotta deal with five hp well you
got to deal with it oh there you go
shoe shine back one just the contest
with the wall
saving lives once again there we go big
pressure gets the low oh
and then delays it a little bit still
gets the hit extra man has a chance now
we're still in this first game
shooting star
the running three
wow
get off of me it's my new dress i don't
want you to touch me
down back forward just the tail end of
it the myla address
i like these folks extra men are
starting to go to instead of committing
to some of these bigger moves
get off of me there we go
down back four finds this mark
the rage
is 500 milligrams rage on the table
oh my god that pressure arc blast good
punish excrement
quick cancel on the stance shooting star
to steal the round excrement you've been
extra man
extra mitchell being extra man
oh
okay
uh uh oh let me get the wall yo don't do
it don't do it don't take bro oh that
was dangerous
oh boy
oh okay we're good we're good
attrition right now it's anyone's game
no okay went for the grab that's pretty
common
oh
my
god what a check
wow
yeah i thought that he would he would
roll out from the wall splat but he
caught him right there for the last hit
so yeah extra man taking the first match
right now
looking pretty tough for 500.
fighting it yeah it's just nice
fighting it i really do like this uh
extra man with the lane just really
going back and forth there was never a
time where you saw 500 literally just
stay with that lead even if the pokes
were really strong where the lows were
really switching up and trying to find
the opening yeah really didn't break the
focus of extra man and that's really
what you want to do with ling if you can
get it lean to be aggressive and you can
just make your opponent hesitate even
slightly it comes out in ling's favor uh
we saw a back turn duck with aop to get
under the ark blast like are you serious
like i would have been yeah that was
mentally distraught he plowed a blank
bro
yeah yeah yeah she just ducked my arm
glass back turned like i would have been
tight like yeah yeah yeah that that hurt
i saw that i was like man
i'm glad i'm i didn't like input that
arc blast man
i wouldn't want that to be in my hands
right now that was pretty tough
i legit just would have been staring in
this i would just been well i'm like for
real bad dynamco please oh
in the gym interesting choice okay
i wonder what the thought process behind
that was for the shape of the stage yeah
it's a pretty decent station when it
comes to calculating your your sense of
wars basement
so that's really pretty decent look at
that i just realized that he's got an 11
win streak on his goddamn account
what are you trying to impose with him
nah that's what you're supposed to do if
you come into a tournament you just
gotta get the longest win streak get it
like a 50 game win streak and then come
into the tournament and you're like man
am i going to be able to stop this guy
like
there you go
i like them dancing a little bit here
or goes for the hop kick tries to go for
the aop roll but didn't work out get the
boost up from back turn no block on the
low this time gonna get really close to
the wall
back turn lower
using the ankles and the shooting start
again
doing numbers yeah it's been doing
numbers
wow
one plus two
but yeah okay
oh wow and just because they actually
dropped the combo but extra man actually
got the wow wait a minute
there we go picks him out of the air
they can get the wall here
goes for the shoe shine no good gets the
grab no break very nice
bolt and racing
that was exciting
all right that was garlic that was god
like all right okay
i like the knowledge
shoulder
good punish
goes in the raw aop gets the counter
head
look at this guy okay
okay
okay
you can tell yeah using an aop duck
speaking of round
okay still on the board for extra mint
okay shuts him up
oh okay we got those two lars got those
two
i was wondering when we were gonna start
seeing them
if i would have saw if you would have
ducked my my arc blast back time i
literally would have started doing orbit
instantly
on the board on the board there he is
okay this is his chance to get an
official one point
let's see
i like the change up in pace here
500 taking the time
patience nice little punish
okay oh doesn't get away punished on
that
kind of tough it's scary to get in there
even though you see the opportunity
sometimes not worth the risk
there we go you're baiting out the
orbital
takes the mid option
patience on both sides here
yeah yeah yeah
lively yeah we're like half with 30
seconds in and it's pretty big life
leads
oh he doesn't get a chance
needs this round absolutely needs this
round this is winner side so still has a
chance on the loser's side but you don't
even want to go that far
decent
10 seconds just about left on the clock
movement going into overtime for extra
man
oh my god that could have been big okay
this is the longer he sees it and it
denies it
wow that felt sloppy man oh like i
imagine like these guys like their hands
are trembling on trying to get it right
it could have ended right but he didn't
i was like oh my god okay
500 mil staying alive
another chance a redemption let's see
let's see this is a tough match dude
these have been like two games already
and it's been to the wire all of them i
like this i like this i like the blue
like the slug like the background yeah
yes yes yes
it's like some hajimeno stuff you know
what i'm saying but they just like beat
the crap out of each other it's like
this you say in the real world that that
would have stopped like 20 minutes ago
but they're still going dude look that's
why digital violence is okay in my book
bro you can beat the crap out of each
other in video games bro and then you
just go back yeah select screen and do
it all over again there's nothing wrong
with violence bro
yeah yeah
let's see what choices they've made i
think extra mint will probably keep the
xiaohu is the strongest pick let's see
if he picks a state oh jungle outpost
yep that's a good choice he does he does
fall back to this stage a lot
well the set's tired on winning inside
right now
look at the the tours we get of these
stages i'm telling you right yeah this
is they started doing this i started
figuring out other stuff all over the
stage
i'm like well i didn't even know it was
something back there to look at
extra mystery
and get the launch oh yeah
oh breaking the balcony there we go
early already ten seconds i thought i
was gonna get the side switch but no
back turn art blast hits let's see if
there's a combo there is none
yeah i was like we're gonna get a wall
break now
later later there it is standing pool
okay push and pull trying to bait out
something out of him
i love i love the bait beautifully
gets the wall bounce and the route
extraman drawn first blood in this last
game
and by blood i mean
bubble
nice tail sweep
yup
okay
keeping that mid pressure
and look how much
look how much slower
i said though
oh my god
oh nice gets the hard knock down four
four four
okay
extra min doing a lot of push and pull
coming in and out trying to overextend
uh 500 mils 500 500 mils feeling the
pressure he needs like to end this so he
has to like take more risks
putting himself in a bad position but
he's getting some damage in there but
look man
down four once all the orbitals
cares bro that was the five hp
that's right that was a little steamy
there but not enough
damn look at that picking him yeah
that's a hp stimmy
counter hit down back four
yo 500 okay on a rampage right now oh no
break on the oneplus 2 though
oh i'm gonna big damage oh no what
happened
wha okay
keeping it cool don't make too many
risks oh there's a way to throw again
trying to get those orbitals to work for
him but they're not doing much oh
there's another one
oh there it is wow
you could be dead
this could you might be dead oh still
alive
oh let's go
still match point
count back four
500 turning up the offense a little bit
here
again he's going to be versing yagami
this is very interesting man
oh boy like let me check like excrement
yeah he was the winner of like the
tournament a couple days ago and 500
mills was second place
cycles it's happening again oh man as we
said
you know it's funny because
i always see
i now i'm to the point where i'm playing
tekken and i'm like bro i have to have
like back turn combos you have to have
that stuff that yeah so
now every time i see one i'm like
i feel like i'm exposed every time i see
a back turn combo from my character
because i'm like oh they can do it right
i was like because i always just say ah
dragon doesn't have good back turn
combos and then like i see subject or
something do when i'm like i'm just
trying to avoid homework right that's
what i'm doing that's like that's really
awesome
because you have no homework
it's now like that's part of the that's
part of the scramble now like well look
if they get a back turn where they don't
have a combo you can say well look
that's still a situation that you can
take advantage of because you can put
yourself here and know that you're not
going to die from it so you have to have
a photo to deal with some of these back
turn situations and some of these catty
corner combos
do you find that uh the cross-up combo
is like a thing that's been popping up
in the past year and a half like the
crossover ones like i've been seeing it
way more in the past couple years it's
been nuts like every character's got one
from
no you're right like i think it's just
people are starting to to discover that
it's
like an evolution that i've noticed
uh the meta is actually changing for a
lot of the tools and stuff that you
don't typically get to see used
in uh the meta right like there's a lot
of game there's a lot of times where you
don't see that meta evolve until later
in the life span but we've been playing
tekken 7 for a while now so it's really
no surprise that oh yeah at this point
now that we're getting there right
oh yeah well
also
yeah go ahead talk to him man
yeah yeah so you know it ain't over
there's still a week to go but there are
more regional events coming up for the
online challenge for 2021 as you can see
we're region 12 right now but there's a
couple more coming up korea and japan
and the regional finals as you can see
on the right side are all coming up
huge amounts are taken to be played so
don't forget to sign up when you have
when if you can do it there's only like
seven days left it ends october 10th
we're from the future it's the third
already so we got seven days but you
guys might have an extra day to go to
submit your application while you can of
course you can register um at the uh
tekken
esports dot bn-ent.net
and follow all the steps it's a little
bit confusing at first but once you
follow the instructions it's all very
clear and then you can sign in for your
local tournaments where you are because
you don't want to miss opportunity it's
really good like you know everybody's
fight for it really good games you can
like you know relax a bit and like test
your skill a lot of people been playing
at home and you know you gotta you gotta
put the rubber on the road sometimes you
gotta turn up to an event even though it
might not be offline but you know you
still that pressure that tournament
pressure is a higher skill
you get used to it
yeah yeah
and you have to be able to you know kind
of harness it especially in situations
like this whether it be offline or
whether it be online for me sometimes
it's a lot harder to adjust online so i
got a lot of respect for these players
out here man you're going to be right
setting up that winner's final uh
and that's who we're going to have for
the winners finals to see who's going to
go to the grand finals first who's going
to get that first spot uh of course the
next match is coming up for you guys we
saw scorpion earlier with the king but
scorpion gonna be going up against
wowzer then after that we got natural
going up against a friendly tree those
are going to be the next two sets we
have for you guys i believe the the
scorpion match is going to be on loser's
side if i'm not mistaken yeah i think it
is yeah these are both of those matches
are going to be uh yeah everything's new
inside yeah
yeah
so it's gonna be interesting to see what
they're gonna pick so we've got right
now in the loser's side we have
two new zealand players and then four uh
australian players so that's not bad
that's a four to six quarter two split
not bad
and yeah so we'll see yeah go on
somebody in the chat asking uh that's
fine okay i actually saw somebody in the
chat asking where were the new zealand
players so i'm glad that you actually
pointed out all right there you go
yeah yeah yeah they're right there so
yeah it's going to be good to see what
they're going to pull out um
let's see what is going to be like the
top i would say or up three what the
representation is going to be at that
level it's pretty tough
and oh let me check the uh the points as
well okay that's another thing i'm just
thinking about that i was about to say
uh first place it gets 300 points right
so yeah these players whether you're at
the bottom of that top eight with points
wise or in the middle of it if you get
that 300 points you're instantly in
first place at this point because like
you said the people who have been
playing and placing in these tournaments
they're not going too far away from each
other and the more different that the
player is or the variety that it is that
means when these events happen whoever
gets that first second third place
they're gonna get so many points to
secure themselves for that potential
regional final
yeah i think like i'm just trying to i'm
roughing the numbers in my mind right
now and already
like i think that um
scorpio and wowzer and all that they've
already pushed themselves to that
threshold with 45 points
so it's just a matter of like if they
can get more and more e-cut out and
secure the position a lot of these
people have almost guaranteed a spot for
themselves so it's gonna be really
interesting to see
this play out and then give it three
months of preparation and then we're
gonna watch the finals in december
and see like you know how that
preparation is going to play out because
it's going to be pretty similar matchups
that are going to happen so this is like
their first time to try it out and see
how it's going to play out so it's going
to be really interesting to see i'm
going to do a comparing contrast later
hey the comparing contrast you got to
make the circle graphs the good the bad
things in between
well yo shout out to everybody watching
at home man this is the technical hell
yeah online challenge oceania if you
guys know the region you should be
showing a lot of respect to these
players i love the fact that the take
online challenge is going to the
specific regions to showcase these
players and the fact that they're
getting a lot of screen time because
they're on their very own stream and
this is what the tekken online challenge
does these guys are trying to get points
so they can qualify for that big
regional final that's why points are on
the line and that's why the tekken is so
good yo yiggs i see you in the chat
oh yeah yeah he was gonna be um
participating but um
he's
he's got something even greater than the
challenge he
he just um he's a dad you know he's got
a new baby right there yes he's very
good can i make some noise in the chat
can y'all please make some noise
everybody yo daddy that is in the chat
what's good man congratulations bro i
didn't know you had a little one out
here i can't believe you're here making
children you need to be responsible stop
playing video games i'm just kidding
never stop playing video games congrats
though homie congrats though homie
my man out here changing diapers with
the tekken hands oh bro
all right here we go legacy
the legacy skills there you go okay
wowza with the knee with the um
this is a forbidden word in my
vocabulary that's why it's like oh wow
do it double placed it with negan huh
yeah yeah i like [ __ ] dude he's
underrated
he's like my favorite guest character by
far
bro i think it's so cool man that i
still think it's crazy that we have
jeffrey dean morgan in tekken bro like
i'm
saying actually crazy because i'm
telling you right now if the chance ever
comes where i meet him i'll be like i
can't believe you're in tekken bro do
you know how powerful that is he's like
dude i'm the best
wayne i'm like i know he's got i'm the
comedian you know in a movie i'm like
dude i get it
but you're jeffrey d morgan and you're
in tekken bro you're in cursing
there's not a lot of people to get to do
that
yeah yeah that's a repeat
okay there's an order for you
boy he's giving him the smorgasbord okay
oh he goes right over yeah yeah you
can't break the wall oh no actually you
take the powerbomb
for a stomp oh okay well this is this is
definitely possible wow's it
pokes them
oh yo
down 4-1 and gets out of the range of
the devil
wait a minute yo wowser oh my god he
stole that yep
wowza just his play style with any
character is a tree i just love watching
wilder's play stuff
damn he hit him with the chest hair
freshly shaved chest
it's that prickly chest that's why he
got him stunned him mm-hmm
you don't even know what it is it's like
man i don't know if i was annoyed or i
want a giggle that's going to hit the
wall
am i annoyed that i'm giggling i don't
know hey look i don't even know what you
wanted i don't even know what happened
am i turned on or am i i know it i don't
know
goes for the low
oh my god look at this i'm annoying
right now
god like how does he do this man it's
crazy how he had like one like that that
you know that corrado steamy hp steamy
and he managed to bring the health all
the way back though right like even
though it was one tap away just that
push and pull getting in getting his hit
going out and then just chipping from
the distance that he's got with his tool
kit and there you go just gets the round
yeah nachos does have to fish a little
bit to get like big watch damage at the
tail end right so
going for the poke sticking to the poke
game is really really smart because you
expect if even if i have that lead right
like i'm i'm expecting you to go for
something big i'm not thinking that
you're gonna keep going for these small
pokes uh just to like keep the match
going on a little bit longer that takes
a lot to do especially in situations
these top eight situations where you got
to keep your wits about you so i like
the play style man the noctis getting
the job done
oh yeah
and it's not a very common character you
see in tournament play like even when i
went to evo
and you know that's when you see a lot
of play right so how many matches there
it was a probably a couple two or three
necklaces that were just like very good
like that you'd see them and they'll
just do really well
so as we said like our character paul
oppa hey
hello the zuya's out finally yeah the
guest character from super smash bros
ultimate is here bro i can't believe the
character from they got a stage from
super smash brothers
let's go dlc supremacy dlc supremacy
let's go you guys going to be cracked
i'm telling you what
man i'm going to tell you right now man
i love that i love the tears bro
oh god the electrics you're going to hit
him with three in the beginning of the
round you disrespectful
that's called bread and butter in the
casio world okay three electrics is
breaking three electrics is the bread
and butter
that's your car vegemite and toast
that's the vegemite and butter dude
make sure you tell them how much
vegemite
how much vegetables
he just spoons it straight out though he
doesn't give a damn he treats like
nutella
why would you talk about kazuya players
like that bro you just go sit there
eating spoonfuls
oh my god
chad yes
i'ma tell you right now if i come back
and i catch somebody doing that i'm just
gonna slap it out their hand man i'm
like you need jesus man you can't be out
here eating vegemite like this bro this
can't be healthy
this can't be healthy
a lot of sodium too much salt
yo the butter knife
oh the wall split
okay that should do it there you go that
was a pretty decent round look pretty
long
and it's all pulled up
wowzers not getting any big combos but
still staying alive just as i say that
the oneplus 2 yeah but it's not
generally not what it's part of his
style he's not really looking for that
he's looking for like it look it seems
like he does combos as like a bonus
look at that right he's godlike it's got
like it's like if he gets a combo
opportunity oh [ __ ] i'll take it but i
don't need it
yo man i love that move
hi hi watch out
is going to the living room going to put
on his pants go to the living room
scorpion out of this tlc wows are going
to stay alive in the loser's side of
things that is a yeah the character
switch was pretty telling the character
switch was actually pretty telling for
scorpion uh once he see that the king
was not working out and the noctis game
plan like i said we didn't see any big
combos it was more about the poker yeah
got annoyed and yeah got hit by one big
counter i feel like we only saw one big
counter hit come from noctis you know
the rest was literally yeah yeah right
and the rest was all kind of like
twisted just caught you moving you know
yeah yeah and that's the thing is that
uh noctis has a very nice toolkit for
that annoying pokey style yeah like a
lot of people focus on the big orders
and the big risky moves that's not as
like big of a deal as like that's
whatever but these little things like
you know unparriable lows and all that
kind of weird stuff
you know throwing throws off your game
and gets you angry i i don't know like
there's a bias i would say anti-noctis
bias where people already start angry
like i'm not this guy again
and then you know then they verse wowzer
which knows how to actually use him and
then you're in deep [ __ ] and it's like
okay well there you go
but yeah so that means that you have to
be able to do it
no no but that means wowza will be
versing um 500 mils so he has to
mentally get ready for that matchup as
well
and now we're going to be having another
new zealand versus australia match which
is going to be natural versus a friendly
tree
so that's going to be pretty interesting
bro
don't need a chance if that's going to
rain
yeah that could be it that's i'm taking
four vibes right now right absolutely a
little bit
yeah that's a lot of it bro that was
that's that was like world finals
matches right there that was jen versus
yeah yeah
versus nina with the unblockable bro
they gave my man jim the unblock we'll
bring it back bro bring back the unblock
i'm halfway joking
i'm
i didn't make the rules but i will take
advantage of them
500 milligrams going up against wowzer
on that loser side still two out of
three territory but i think we're gonna
get natural going up against a friendly
tree first with the nina uh and
obviously uh versed nina at this point
this is gonna be tough i feel like uh
you have to have some expertise with gin
if you're gonna fully slow down anina
yes yes i was gonna say yeah yeah that
makes sense yeah
so if it's expertise natural's got it
like it's in the name he's just got it
so we'll see
let's see if he's gonna
hey
i didn't make the rules dude
so yeah we'll see how it's gonna play
out hey
and a friendly tree uh yeah well let's
say
let's see what his gin matchup knowledge
is because you just don't see gin as
much as you used to
but it's it's both an unfamiliar match
up it's like a gin match up which is
kind of like not as big as it used to be
and the nina matchup which is very rare
even within australia we do have nina
players but they're not as many as you
think
is that the same in america as well i
imagine like even when i went to evo i
met one guy that played nathan
yeah yeah yeah like you don't see a lot
of arenas in general a lot of we have
like our staple ninas like silence yeah
it's one of the meanest that i'm
completely familiar with we had a crazy
nina papa up at icfc and i can't
remember his name please forgive me
i'm telling you right and he was re i'm
talking about ridiculous he got like top
eight at icfc and i think it was they
got like third or fourth place or
something like that but that's what the
thing is about nina and nina will pop up
and literally blow you up and you'll be
like yo i have no idea about how to deal
with this thing you know
the match-up knowledge will pop you
severely you can't wing it with nina
but yeah okay we've got hot topic gin
ready to go we got you know uh spring
nina over here that's all right
i can't recommend the officers are
important
michael murphy okay okay he used to
dress like this and i hundred i've seen
the pictures yeah i've seen i've seen
footage i've seen footage
there we go getting the first round
pretty solid from uh natural
let's see this is an interesting stage
of shoes or they didn't or it was random
selected but we're going to see how the
infinite part is going to play out as
well which is interesting
friendly tree not getting the optimal
wall enders for some of these combos
though
yeah and i think it's really starting to
like catch up with them especially if
natural just uses the fourth off come on
and catching freely ducking so many
times he went for the he went for the
four four three one like start up again
so you can use like one two three one
and if you get the four the the three to
hit you still get the free juggle with
one you can go right into one two four
it's kind of crazy and natural just
taking advantage of it you see it right
there it literally did exactly what i
just said
nice oh wait a minute okay finally he
can start getting his game going because
it looks like a friendly trick just
couldn't engage in his play yet but now
he's getting his first opportunities in
took him two rounds though which is kind
of tough
there we go trying to back out a bit
down back with the delay with the audio
delay it's a bit tragic i'm not gonna
lie
[Laughter]
it's like a second chorus that follows
afterwards you know it's a call and
response oh you've got the gameplay
doing the one and then you're doing it a
bit later and it layers up that's that's
some high tech okay
that's some like baroque stuff that's
pretty cool that's okay ah
it's the tail spirit
i really want to do this part but at the
echo
four four oh nice punish it just goes
for the hell sweep this [ __ ]
oh no not enough
hey
beyond that point you gotta take care of
yourself okay he gives you five you
gotta do something with it okay
with it
don't ask me for [ __ ] don't ask me for
nothing i gave you what you wanted
get the t-shirt you don't have to watch
don't make me tap the shirt people say
tap the snap around be like yo don't
make me tap the shirt
video game players don't ask me for [ __ ]
on the skin uh
the nina
the nina is a character once again that
i feel like you can really take
advantage of that match-up knowledge i
feel like that's one of the characters
in this game all this can't have to all
the characters in the game but even more
so with nina it's easy to fall by the
wayside because you don't know what to
deal with if you have even a little bit
of neenah knowledge it goes a long way
and i feel like that's what we saw here
like coming from the gym
yeah as long as you know like the basics
to just
you know keep your ground steady
it's just a matter of maintaining your
game and that's what was an issue like
he was always one step ahead it felt
like the whole time he was just like
always challenging him and not allowing
him to like start the blender just like
okay i'm gonna start now not denied
objective objective object violet
systems okay
interesting choice
but nina what would nino okay maybe it's
just a feng shui thing it's like they
dig the vibe
the thing is nina you can do these
combos you get in the wall a lot of the
time there's not too many angles that's
not gonna give you the wall yeah i guess
yeah so i do like the stage
i i mean in general i just like the
stage i like the music but if you got
decent wall gary like lars on this stage
my man can get the wall no man
well check this out combo video
oh wow oh daddy
butterflies no just takes the spike okay
down back three to get the closer it's
nice back once adding up
there it is there you go okay friendly
tree taking some momentum
oh counter head
while standing four back to one
definitely getting the wall uh uh uh uh
four four three not going to work on us
using four four against the wall not too
sure about it
four four three try to use that charge
blind bomb not gonna work out
staying at four
oh this is this is your early tense oh
that's no good damn
one a piece
yo my man starting off every round with
an electric just to let you know
oh yeah
and that's gonna get the wall yeah that
low power is a bit
there we go
and indeed
gotta block oh goes the delay hop no
good oh
it's crushed
a little cheeky with the delayed hard
kick down four one four gets the wall
split and the combo on top of it there
we go
goes the slide
gets the wake up low
and jab
no chill okay match point right now for
natural let's see if he's going to
eliminate a friendly tree from this top
eight
oh damn
doesn't get the follow-up gets the
spring kick
out of a line
glow
okay wait a minute a friendly tree
goes for a reese oh there's the cross up
and now put yourself against the wall
nice and launching oh drop the combo
there it is okay
this could be the make or break for a
friendly tree
nice a little bit out of space
damn natural becoming a ball of thorns
right now not only giving him any room
to come in goes right underneath that
one
wow
for that big loss thank you like
a big one
there's the butterflies
please somebody clip another one let's
do it again no he drops a misalignment
gets caught in the water
oh
it
god wow i thought it would roll out and
it does not
unnatural moving forward with a 2-0
against a friendly tree
this was wild that final round was
something damn
wow
that was good oh
man
oh man i definitely didn't think that
rage art was going to hit on the wall
like that
i definitely yeah
wow
well that's gonna do it man
oh man a friendly tree out of there out
of there not gonna make it any further
in this top eight that was loser's side
but still
the matches go on we still got plenty of
matches left in this top eight um
natural with the gin though just being
really abusive with just
the fact that a friendly tree was really
playing this up close game and it was
some combos i felt like just really
didn't pay off i felt like there was a
little too much damage just left on the
table in some instances
right right
but yeah like
now we've got
okay i'm looking at the brackets right
now so we've got 500 mils of trend per
week versus wowzer and then we're going
to have genuine gaming's deon great
versus natural
can be pretty interesting to watch and
lose side i think we're going to get our
next match is going to be 500 milligrams
versus uh wowza
that's another new zealand versus uh
australia match okay it's gonna be that
okay
so both um new zealanders stay to the
next round so they're moving along so
we'll see
well before we even get to that match i
believe we have some cool shirts for the
people at home if you try to get this
good ass tech and not just play it but
also wear it make sure you use this qr
code or head on over to 10-0 dot gg
slash merch to get your very own
versions of good ass tekken with nina
king
law as well as paul or you can get this
cute ass taken we got julia we got leroy
and sugar we got the twins we also got
the kings as well you guys can make sure
you can get these shirts especially the
good ass tekken king and law which are
back because they were only up for a
limited run you can get your very own
man shout out to tenno for giving us
this official tekken merch this official
good ass tekken merch
as well
[Music]
and there we go the socials so if you
want to keep up with everything taken
online challenge related
don't forget that we are everywhere so
you can go on twitter bne esports we got
taken twitch slash taken and of course
if you want to catch the vods later it's
always up there at bne esports and hey
you want to talk to your grandma and you
also want to check up on tekken hey we
got facebook they're there as well dude
you can check them out you can do it
no matter what you it's part of the day
you're in there's always tech and news
available for you at any location and of
course
we're gonna go for a short little break
and you know rehydrate yourself and get
ready for the following up top eight
matches don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
so
welcome back to tekken online challenge
oceania representing i am joined by
petro rose i like to roll the rs i did
that on purpose how are you doing how
are you enjoying these matches
it's been a pleasure sharing the mic
with you i gotta say just fyi yeah man
pretty killer dude yeah yeah i'm pretty
excited as well and you know hopefully
in the future we get to do it in person
but yeah it's been good for me it's
business as usual okay oc tekken is
always top tier it's always popping it's
always got variety always got upsets so
i'm just it's another day in the office
but you know i'm glad that i get the
shirt to share that with you know with
the rest of the world so you know it's
always good to be able to do this
yeah how about you what are you thinking
about this um you know tournament so far
i'm thinking that it's really cool that
i can hurt things so well and my
co-commentary partner that's because
astro is the official headset and mix
amp sponsor of the tekken online
challenge if you like the soothing
sounds of petrol rose and tasty steve
just make sure you show some love to
astro who holds down the tekken
community as well as a lot of the
fighting game community has been doing
it consecutively as we get back to this
topic
the layout for the layoff st that was
right that was good that was good
and yeah dude here we are midway through
this top eight bracket winners final we
have dht's yagami versus extra mint
uh losers quarter final we've got 500
milligrams of trend per week versus
wowzer and genuine gaming's dion gray
versus natural
this is coming you know the attrition's
kicking in it's slowly step by step
we have to like you know say goodbye to
these top players but you know say hello
to the next matches that are coming up
so
it's interesting to see how it's going
to play out i think our first match back
will be on the loser's side
um oh actually no winners final we're
going to go straight to the first one
i think so
okay
let's see well i'm not that's not 100
sure we'll see we'll see
um but yeah
things are getting spicy right now
things getting spicy
now you mentioned it it's getting uh to
the end of the tournament right so it's
all about finishing out strong at this
point and it's not really easy because
now people have seen you play you got a
target on your back because the first
spots get the most points right and all
you're doing now is trying to mess up
the regular order of things so you can
be the person potentially to get the
most points out of this uh this
tournament transaction but it's not
going gonna be easy i feel like we've
seen a lot of turnarounds when it comes
to some of these rounds
so yeah like we're talking about like
first place is 300 points flat out
you're dominating second place 220
you're dominating and the third place
150 you're already like top four like
automatically so everything's going to
be shifting at this point and yeah it's
going to be interesting to see i think
there's one more event the the close-off
period is on the 10th as you all guys
know sign up while you can and i think
there's one more tournament uh dojo for
the oceania region which is going to be
in auckland i think in new zealand
oh okay
do that to jump in squeeze some points
maybe knock out the eighth place guy and
get in there real quick you know you got
a chance because you know december is
the big one okay so you can't miss that
one
yeah and now we're getting ready to get
some points you really want to get some
points you want to get on that big stage
and possibly sleep
you can't sleep on that stuff you
absolutely can't because i'm gonna tell
you right now the more experience you
get in the online world of tekken
because you're gonna need it the better
i promise you you will always play
better as long as you get that it's
yeah yeah it's like another skill on the
skill tree of being of competitive play
it's not just the game it's also the
tension you gotta like you know it's
like forced on the fire you need to put
yourself under that stress
and get used to it it's not like it's
going to get better your your
ability to deal with it gets better it's
not like it just becomes easier you
become stronger so you just got to test
it any available ability yeah
yes exactly
and we got the bob out i like this
okay this is one another character he's
been playing recently
um and getting good results with his
what the humpty bob the outfit okay i
actually hate this outfit bro i hate
this yeah
he that's all he wears
500 milligrams of trend
always where's the humpty bob the outfit
guaranteed oh my god
all right
a little earlier too right oh nice yeah
this is big damage oh no didn't get the
full connection right there just a
little low
wow
tries to go back in
yeah those strings especially coming
from bob if you don't know how many hits
in it a lot of times they're going to
come back around and track you so guy
caught sidestepping a little bit with
that one yeah
yeah midstream that just realigned on
you and popped you for it there it is no
goes for the punishable version no good
oh denied
no break
wow
okay this is gonna be some serious
damage
oh boy
ah that's gonna be tough to get out of
fight
all right okay so you can take the lead
yeah one round a piece i like the like i
like the pace that they're both playing
at right now gets the tackle
going back to the abuser i liked it
okay big big folks this time gets the
counter here
no big converse just chip
look at the damage wow he gets the hit
okay full combo with the blue stuff
you get the wall there it is
you shine not good
he's gonna get the sweep no it goes for
the regular look okay
back and there it is just to close out
round four
why take big risks
yeah back twos are going through the
catch people like oh yeah while they're
trying to move especially against the
wall
okay
applying some pressure whoop right back
at him
yeah once he gets like you know as i've
i've been saying this for years bobby's
a true son of heihachi not lars he's got
the toolkit okay he's a true mishima he
went to vegas
and apparently bob didn't stay in vegas
he left and now here he is dude
so hey stuff happens
yo he's playing this i like the pace
that he's playing at right now yeah
damn okay to the wire to the wire
oh yeah once um bob goes full machine
mode weibo goes into the the low stress
he hasn't really got into that play yet
he's very held back trying to get that
counter here to get a proper launch and
then he gets a lot harder
versus alyssa because like and this is
what you mentioned like she can be a lot
more aggressive like you see right there
even though like bob has some of the
better pokes in it in the game that
crouch dash won a lot of strings that
you have to respect
alisa is one of those characters that
we've already mentioned the offense goes
up a lot higher because they've made her
a more aggressive character this season
especially with like chainsaws fans and
just being able to kind of harass any
character that she wants to at this
point not so much the the leroys or the
[ __ ] rounds because of the strings uh
characters with like quick back ones and
stuff like that they can you know make
you control that up close counter hit
game but a lot of the other characters
they really have to respect the spacing
that elisa puts on you like and the
place that she plays at
yeah yeah it's become a high tempo
character and
if you're not willing to like be feel
comfortable under that fire you just get
beaten up it's really stressful
like you better you know
get around it and it's hard to get
around i was gonna like just when i
realized with all the lateral movement
which is insane it's always gritted up
on you you can't really sneak around her
in any way she can always catch up with
you yeah because she has a very very
tragic
she has a lot of great tracking movies
her side step is really good as well so
you have to respect it yeah and if you
try to fight that little scramble um
that's when she really starts to get to
hit you with a lot of those tracking
moves standing for being one of them
yeah a lot of people always ask why her
rage drive hits so much it's because
people try to do quick side steps to get
away from those pokes yeah you get
garage
one time and then it's like well i just
lost the round because of it and a lot
of elise's they paced around for to see
if you're going to get hit by those
kinds of things but here we go game
number two wowzer and 500 for 500 with
the big dax down back four and gets the
wall but didn't get the shoulder
there we go no break getting the wall
pressure
you can poke him in the corner and get
the warp splat into a nicely aligned
combo bringing him to another wall maybe
no good okay there it is
bounce into break let's see oh my god
and in the rain
no i don't think so but god damn is in a
good position
and there it is right at the corner but
your account hit away from losing your
account oh my god that was so smart
that was so slick
bro okay okay that's wowza for you dude
yeah okay all right oh he actually just
hit me with the wowzer because i
definitely was surprised i was like bro
you're about to get hit something crazy
oh yeah
oh nice
okay
trying to keep
trying to get in there but um 500 mil is
always just out poking him
back forward
wall break and steal the tail spin on
top of it oh oh wow
wrong combo quick tech on the wall
while they're in trouble it doesn't get
the punish
rage is on the side oh wow gets out of
there wow that was acrobatic right there
damn okay let's see if he's gonna get a
mid there you go
okay uh-oh
it's it's it's the final round music of
g corp night time yeah you know it is
what it is
look it's got some good parts man that
one little three second
stint on this part of the song i'm
actually a fan
it's the good ass tekken part of the
song oh the sprinkler
oh my god
oh okay okay he's got grabs
now how's this gonna close
tough but he's still in it okay
that would have been it for wowzer
because right now it is still match
point for himself
[Music]
[Applause]
good night
oh wow quick side step gets him out of
trouble
for the down 4-1
right after it
there we go
takes it clean over 500 man the fact
that like wowzer was able to keep the
pace under control even though we saw
like 500 m literally try to like open up
the game like you know what i'm gonna
start going for like these running
threes i'm gonna start trying to open
you up by hitting you with the lows
trying to get you to duck but every time
alisa with the check wowza was not
letting them get away with it was not
letting them get back control of the
pace of these games and that's how you
win
yeah that was that was rough and good
sense of timing putting some spacing
with um wowzer again very patient guy
like he's just really nice to watch that
he can just keep himself on in in check
and just do what he needs to do and just
take what he needs and if something cool
comes up hey extra 80 damage i'll take
it you know it's like whatever right he
doesn't feel like he's stressed about it
he's very calm about it it's a very
um
common pattern when you see wowza play
that's why i i watch wowzer aspiring to
play that but i can never do it i just
like i don't have it in me that that
that super patient play it's like for
example
like for me as a dragon off players like
i'm like always watch jdc i'm like oh
man look this is like an enlightened
person playing card and all that but
then i play like nobody i just can't
help myself i'm just a psycho you know
that's got to do it you know you're like
you've got to backstage in there and
you're going to press something i'm
gonna try it out
i don't blame you i don't blame you man
oh here we go another look at this
topping
we're pretty deep in the thick of things
right now oh yeah dion gray versus
natural should be the next match that
way we'll set up i think we're gonna go
to that loser's side but for the winners
finals to see who's actually gonna get
in the grand finals extra man going up
against yagami on the winner's side uh i
believe that will be first to three so
that means we got a few you got one
extra game to try to figure it out
before you lose that grand final showing
yeah there's more time for you know
information acquisition and like ability
to even take risks to maybe garnish
information let's say i'll throw this
couple rounds to get some patents out of
them i can take the risk first the twos
are really tough you have to be like on
your a-game and like try and just claim
your your territory fast but with first
the threes
the the the angle and approach is a
little bit different you can play it a
little bit different which makes it for
more interesting play and especially
when you're we're seeing matches between
people who frequently play against each
other they kind of do know themselves a
little bit different it's not like a
random tournament that's like okay let
me figure it out now it's like i already
know this guy but how can i subvert
their expectations about what they know
about me it's like that next level play
you know
so we'll see how that's going to play
out
it's really kind of interesting to see
how people are changing up their game
now because now since like there's these
region weeklies and now we have even
more events that's happening to kind of
like highlight like there's a lot of
players that you get to see a lot more
often that means they have like a target
on their back like
cuddle core is one of the strongest
players in the world at this point right
but like yeah
this week on icfc we've seen like
matches where like she's fighting some
of these people that she fights all the
time some of her training partners and
that's when yeah like the only time you
get to see people that are able to even
remotely keep up with that character but
i only yeah to compare it to these
situations because in these top eights
whereas points on the line that's when
you want to take all the information
that you have a little small like ticks
that you remember that an opponent might
have yeah and you play it against them
right here this is when you hold them
against them to try to make sure that
they like actually pay attention to your
sets but dion gray versus natural gonna
be the next match i'm interested to see
if this gin is going to be the pig
i think so i think it's been
oh my god and these guys play against
each other a lot they're you know on
especially online because you know they
used to live in the same place but not
anymore so
they do know each other very well they
do know each other very well um
i just maybe dion okay they're gonna go
full on because i was like in the back
of my mind i'm like maybe dion knows
that let's say when they play he has
difficulty against this particular match
up let me just bring that against them
but no they're going to go full ball on
their best choices so let's see how this
is going to play out this is going to be
i think
uh more aggressive dion we're going to
see a more aggressive deal than normal i
think if i don't make a fall
let's see how it's going to play out
yep this birth style
okay
nothing too risky from natural getting
lots of damage in there
you know i'm trying to get the game in
yeah yeah
there you go
board four
damn look at natural with the perfect
round i like what i see
hey people talking talking ish about the
forward four hey it's pretty good don't
talk
it's nice we still could move we got it
there you go sorry it's pretty good i
think it's nice it still does
very nice but there's some gin mains out
there just you know
playing some crazy stuff
down back four nice searching for the
horse gets this magic four
and looking for the shotgun right there
you see naturally just go right back to
that same one two four string
teasing them with the electrics trying
to get them to swing on something but
you got to be careful up close there's
the hill sweep gin
uh
gets the wall splat
down back four whiffs
goes
where you least expect it damn okay
let's see how you're gonna start okay
more defensive start this time
damn what move is i don't even know what
move that was from leroy
oh gets the counter here
oh wow beautiful with punish bro this
dude natural legit every match hits at
least one electric just to let you know
every every match like yo just just
don't don't you forget about these
electrics bruh
i got the execution he's letting you
know
that was definitely an election okay
there it is
the wake ups okay overheads
guess the wall slide again resetting his
damage
okay this should hit the wall okay in a
weird angle but it didn't roll off there
you go perfect
damn we're back to the final round okay
okay
natural had the lead throughout the
finals yeah
oh yeah
oh magic magic
doesn't get the wall
stop goes for the low option didn't
block it
up big daddy kane out for the final
round again not getting any damage out
of it
getting chipped to death let's see if he
can save himself he's got the whole
pressure
the classic the
round closeout classic the one
down three
who would have thunk it it works man you
can't you can't hate it
the only people that hate it are the
people that eat it that's the problem
that's absolutely true
like come on that's just the fact right
now
but yeah that was a good um return from
uh
from natural because in the beginning i
was like okay he's really got the
control and then theon was like no no no
but then right at the end brought it
back so
it's interesting how he can just like
keep himself his constitution in that
sense so he can just get that win so hey
i'll take it
i mean let's see what dion's gonna do
yeah yeah dion i feel like is is really
uh on the ropes right now um
but
dion definitely when we were watching
him play earlier really did have like
the rebuttal down to a heart like you
really still can play he can play a pace
slow enough to run him himself back in
sets like this so it's not over just yet
and on top of that this is a loser's
side you can't afford to lose one more
match at this point while you're going
home
all right okay it's going back to the
arena okay
so yeah it's a pretty common pattern
with uh dion from
today that we see that he goes back to
arena again it's probably one of my
favorite stages as well it's like that
in an infinite that's usually what i go
for when i play i actually now got the
island paradise that's kind of my new
one
the soundtrack's two op yes it actually
is
all right here we go
smallest stage the wall carry has been
definitely in naturals favor
yeah i feel like naturals been getting a
lot more of the launchers a lot more the
counter hits to get these launchers and
dion gray is still just trying to find a
way to get any game started that's the
wall that's the round
damn this is
quick to surprise
[Music]
okay wait a minute
oh
yeah
wow round three go natural fight
natural's killing it right now
i told you every match they're going
back here just to let you know
oh
oh boy
get a lot of mileage with this hermit
stand
oh yeah we'll crouch down four or four
just rocking
one for me one for you too
i dropped it
it was a setup dude calculated wow
and that is it for genuine gaming's dion
grey
wow he's out that is pretty hectic so
where would that put him in the rankings
that puts him equal fifth i think
uh at this level i think it is
so that means he gets an additional 70
points which gives him roughly 230
something so he's still in it so he will
be at the regional finals so it ain't
over for him but you know he would have
loved it if you could do a you know a
double duty and get both but
okay man that was a huge display from
dion gray and also from natural getting
forward i think that he actually doesn't
even have points so he's actually going
to push himself into the uh into the
finals in one go which is pretty pretty
ball on maneuver that's pretty sick
super good if you don't have any points
that 100 put you on the leaderboard you
are going to be your name is going to be
in the top part part of that leaderboard
especially if you keep this up uh i
can't remember point the point wise it
is already down here at the bottom if
you check out the ticker at the bottom
of the screen you can see who actually
has the lead with the points of the
region right now so and that means the
standings from this tournament is really
gonna change things up
yeah yeah and
so yeah
there are the slides so if yeah go on go
on
and if you want an opportunity to
compete watch along with us these are
the dates this is the third right now so
of course we have korea and japan coming
up on the ninth and the respective tenth
dates if you guys want to check that out
and that's only for the master events we
also got the regional final events
coming up as well we're gonna return to
a bunch of these regions that you've
seen before get a lot more play and see
who's gonna be the king queen winner
champ of said region right now we're in
oceania and there's still time for you
to sign up for these events october 10th
is the deadline if you guys would like
to get a dojo application in and get an
event where points could potentially be
on the horizon you gotta tell the tent
to do it you can't say you haven't been
warned and if you would like to play
make sure that you sign up for that
tekken portal um it also gives you the
opportunity to find out about some
upcoming events so make sure you're
taking dash esports dot bn dash ent dot
net forward slash if you would like to
sign up submissions do close october 8th
so make sure you get an opportunity to
sign up for that esports tournament
portal
there we go dude
so let's get ready for the next battle
dude let's see what we got i've look we
got dhd's yagami versus extra mint for
the winners final and then the losers
final is wowzer versus natural so
there's the new zealand team kill right
there so you know we had to see how far
we're gonna get now we've got we're
gonna get at least one at this point
so yeah that's pretty tight
yeah well
actually someone's really stayed in
winner's side it's not my fault there
you go say it again no you gotta double
down say it again petrol rose say it
again why why is it a team kill
because somebody uh someone should stay
there
that's what i was exactly
petrol said it petrol said i just wanted
to be sure
yeah you got to listen you on the clock
bro you got to hit them with the
messages this is stuff that you see on
refrigerators once they leave the house
petrol said it during the taking online
challenge next
on the
next to the school art next to the
report card it's going to be a quote by
you petrol rose
people are going to touch it before they
leave the house
thank you petrol
i just keep working harder man
gotta do it
that's right because i'm i'm always like
very critical
with the with the oc i'm aware of the oc
guys i'm aware i'm completely aware
that's why i'm like i'm a i'm a tough
love that's my approach when it comes to
the oc guys because whenever we have the
opportunity to actually compete globally
i want everyone to have worked their ass
off when that
rules i want you to know there's another
word for that it's called abuse okay we
don't want to we need to make sure
what you're talking about
what you're talking about
[Laughter]
okay so we've got the wi-fi
first of three now
so let's see how it's going to play out
we're going to get massive leads we're
going to get attrition
oh back turn no good
i like that using these four four moves
to make sure you catch some of the
tracking right there uh especially
versus elisa that's going to be a thing
oh yeah
yo
you guys are spending your money to vote
your
channel points to vote but let me know
in the chat who you got winning this is
it extra men or is it going to be yagami
let me know in the chat
there you go keeping him in check wow
turning around over the cross-up no
bueno
okay with him but stay in aop which is
just as bad as like not like doing
anything just avoid it
okay orbital side step oh boy
so tricky so tricky
oh wow
yeah yeah
orbital no good
big move
power oh there's the running two blocks
the shoe shine okay punish in the
dumpster
oh my god
four mvp today
holy crap
big mids
yagami really paying attention to the
fact that extra man in this xiaoyu wants
to sidestep a lot and you can see it and
just puts herself oh really
gets the counter hit and the combo
though
oh it drops the comeback gets the pick
pickup
turn again god
jesus christ
like they're drawing freaking figure
eights around each other man the amount
of time on both sides is insane
there's been so much variety in these
matches we've had matches that were
based solely around pokes and now the
combos are coming out and gets to throw
three rounds straight extreme
extra minutes
to three right here
i'm gonna i'm gonna have a mint for that
because that was pretty extra mint dude
i have that
extra no onions needed it's just so
fresh that i needed my breath to be
minty when i talked about it okay
petrol
a shrek free zone here okay no onions we
don't do that
yo
yo
panther rolls
what's up
[Music]
next time
this is what you do i'm going to tell
you what you do next time you commentate
the match you just shake you just shake
it in the background you just what's
that noise what noise are you talking
about oh that's just my extra you just
hit it with that like it's running
behind like it's galloping behind you
just
what's that noise is it christmas time
no baby that's extra man
extra man let's go that's right he needs
to get a sponsorship he needs to get
sponsored by like something like mint
company
yo you helping him out right now you
better tell him to include you on the
deal okay i was here for this oh yeah if
i find his face ten percent
there you go man you are a businessman
talking smack
to the fellow region as well as making
sure they breath don't stink you're a
stand-up guy here we go man hey
[Music]
it's almost gonna be growing up here
there we go
[Laughter]
wow
don't break on the one plus two oh my
god
okay
what the yeah he's gonna have to mix up
once again i want to see how these side
steps are going to help you got me out
because you got me that's one of the
things that you got me really changed up
was tracking extra men with the sidestep
tries to use the blue stuff down jab to
stop the pressure side step on the
running three that was definitely going
to be an aop transition but great
sidestep for alisa and that's one of the
things you got to look for man just like
she's using those tracking moves just
like you see right there you got to use
tracking moves to stop her from side
stepping it's too good
wow god it's vacation full combo
oh shoot
true shine i don't know if there's a
next level tech right there
okay he's trying to pursue even though
he's at low health he's really getting
in there
i don't get that orbitals connect but no
good i will low crush i guess
damn okay so yagami's on this track to
like catch up real quick right now
oh it's coming up
all right nice and slow
oh okay that's pretty raw one okay i
don't know
reverse get it off of me
oh i step on that damn that was quick oh
no back roll right there gives you a
free follow up you see that alignment
oh wow
[Music]
and just i thought around
the goal that was that was a damn quick
round there's going to be two actually i
think that's going to be one oh one up
now one one now you got it uh ties it up
now one one
versus extra
damn so this is gonna be back and forth
i have a feeling it's going to be back
and forth
now the the choice of infinite stage
worked out for him
you know having the alyssa to be able to
move freely around
i just did a job so huh
i see what yaga means um with extreme it
might go jungle might go outpost
we'll see we'll see
ah the jungle outpost we might see a
return of huh
but yeah the ling is uh i can tell you
right now the ling is moving uh really
making sure that alisa does not have an
easy time like knowing where to attack a
lot of like uh the running threes really
starting to kind of backfire versus
elisa because she could just walk around
it in a lot of instances so you really
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you got to be tight with the strings
this time around yeah just like you said
man jungle outpost too that's where
we're going uh we've seen this before uh
with the ling so a lot of chances to
break the balcony uh i feel like the
transitional issues uh instances like
the balcony break uh the bottom wall
break as well are all really good
answers for ling but of course elisa can
take advantage of him too but i feel
like movement wise yeah ling is really
good at positioning herself to break
those walls in some instances it's even
better than at least
oh wow go right underneath that
oh my gosh
you're
damn you got me in fast forward right
now
look at these sidewalks and look at what
it's doing for ugami's outfits
um
playing back pretty far right now you're
coming with the people we're punished
i tried to step out of that no good yeah
oh nice oh my god get the the oh the
whole string oh my god
round three oh yagami seems to found it
seems like he's found the secret strat
to take out extra mint right now
there's a standing four
so we punish
bounce damn wall bounce
big damage your mommy trying to use the
sprinkler good punch sprinkler yep
three is that dude brown let's do the
ground the no round brown again oh my
gosh yeah that's doodoo brown that's
that's the big double
damn
that's what i'm like somebody's trying
to get the grand finals
somebody's trying to get the grand
finals
uh one of these guys that's gonna be
guaranteed nothing less than second
place uh guaranteed to get the
underlying
and possibly get the lead in the region
when it comes to points but uh
man
excrement not looking too good right now
i can tell you that
yeah it's not not i don't know how he
just lost that momentum so drastically
with just like what minor changes
nothing really like what do you think
like a shower you would have to do to
get through at this point
like
he's got all the tools really you know
it's not like anything
out of a wreath it's like they're doing
it seems like they're they're playing
like this this game where it's like all
right i'm going to get into range who's
going to whip first and then the
sidestep games
more more it becomes more of a thing
right so it's all about it seems like
who's making who's sidestep first and on
top of that the fact that like ling is
really trying to press our offense you
see her offense you see a lot of running
threes to get in a lot of those down
back twos and some instances and now you
see
a little further because she doesn't
want to deal with it and it's actually
working out the whiff punishes are
actually working out in her favor
because she's playing backwards so i
feel like ling needs to go in a little
bit more ling has the the
movement she has the offense to where
you can make someone slow down but you
just gotta believe in the offense go a
little more crazy if i do say so
look at that lateral movement from yoga
i mean next level
was
this is the situation that we can like
excel in right here
oh the minor punish
this is back to the wall wow that was so
smart didn't press anything big it's the
rage drive wait a minute
the blue stuff
and just steal back turn lows goes for
the normal throw we saw it worth one
round not gonna work this time spins the
blue all goes for the slide seventeen
seconds goes for the fake out
bro you can't say you don't care he gave
you an extra 5 hp to make it tense for
everybody
oh yeah
it really does make a difference in many
many situations it's pretty kind of
crazy
bro extra man was literally just
fighting back turn because he knew
yagami was looking for the low goes for
the one plus two not gonna work
jabs
they giving him a check sideways
coming from ugami and the throw breaks
or immaculate
spins and the way that he just
challenged it
okay this could be extremely chance to
equal
out nice block
whoa
we're gonna get the wall
that's it boom
get another one before orbital
oh nice
just got out of it
yeah jabs actually working out there
trying to get a magic oh the mids
beautifully done
there you go extra um extra mint
ah
we're gonna
it's coming up it's coming out
let's see
you know what time it
i can smell your breath right now you
might need
an extra me
it's like some weird premise where like
you feel a breath behind you but then
you start to smell it and it smells very
good jesus the situation's real bad
something's going on dude
that's right he's creeping up he's
creeping not going quietly into the
night still fighting to get to grand
finals on the winner's side i don't
blame you because i'm telling you right
now you want that extra set on your side
especially if you've made it to grand
finals
oh yeah yeah it's huge because the thing
is that once you go into loser's side
then you go into the big gauntlet
because you have to go lose this final
grand final reset do it again and then
it's like it's a big stamina run so if
you can just sit pretty in grand final
and just like watch them bash each other
while you just you know relax in that
time you want that advantage and you get
to see what their behaviors are and how
they're acting to get more information
so yeah infinite stage okay okay this is
good for both of them really but i think
alyssa might have the edge on this i'm
not sure let's see
it did work for him last time
yeah like the movement is in there it is
nice
oh nice once again going to the tracking
moves
oh oh this is not looking good against
the following this is flip city right
now
oh my god
god like
watch out he's gonna oh he just wanted
to dash away with something okay
almost worked yeah oh okay extra man
starting strong this round very
aggressive
and just abusing the back turn and this
is the offense that i was talking about
you can see extreme gives a lot of
opportunities to go in the aop uh go in
the back turn and your gummy is freezing
a lot of times but i don't think it's
gonna keep working get the combo here
cross up no
goes for the
just when you thought the garlic was
going to be too powerful extra mint
i don't know with grapefruit the garlic
is a bit too powerful i don't know
i know oh trust me i know
damn this could be like a reverse
voodoo brown i think from what i can
tell
it's like six rounds of paul reverse
oh my god okay he's got a lot of damage
in the pocket don't get hit again no
blocks though
wait a minute
and you kept trying to walk
clipped got clipped because we're trying
to walk
by slow powering
trying to bring it back trade
goes for the down four the lows are
starting to add up big tracking move
catches extreme
jab the keeper honest okay goes back to
the lows tries to sidestep again spans
the blue stuff early you got me in a bad
spot gets the launch though
one more could do it shoeshine
oh my god
i could smell that just don't try and
round close to the low and he got low
powered for it which is devastating
don't smell the whole room smell
with the shoe shine
hopping through not gonna work
going back to the lows back to the lows
finishes the string
for the mid goals for the wall gets the
launches this it goes for a reason
second chance
that your gummy runs it back oh my god
unbelievable
the scrambles
the scrambles oh my god
damn this is going to be rough man this
is it's not going to be easy for anybody
so that means
yagami we have a alyssa in the grand
finals for this match and we've got an
alyssa in the losers side
let's see you know we might have a
mirror final we don't know let's see we
got extra mint and natural out there as
well gonna try and give it a go let's
see if extreme can get his run back
um let's see let's see we've got you
know new zealand on the bottom and
there's so many scenarios we can play
out with these remaining matches so as
you can see we've got uh yagami in the
grand final waiting and now we're going
to go to the loser semi-final between
wowza and natural this is going to be
the new zealand's team kill
so let's see what's gonna happen
well only one person it seems like only
one person gonna be able to represent
right
oh that's right that's right
at this point
i don't know who it's gonna be any one
way to find that
i'm gonna see with the chat let's see
the details shout out to sir
so
4896 went for yagami 11
463
channel points
going up for ultimate a lot of people
believe in that extra min that mean none
of you guys breath should stink okay
that's what i'm seeing that's what i'm
reading right now you guys actually care
about your breath extra man oh man what
a set though let me see what this next
thing about
no go ahead my bad i was talking about
the next one oh no no i
got tripped up nah
i'm just saying uh what was i saying i
don't remember don't worry about it it's
just something it's something good ass
taken that's what we're gonna get so
i wonder how this is gonna play out it's
gonna be just because i haven't seen
them two play against each other in a
long time i think probably offline i saw
him somewhere but
um i don't know what their results are
competitively within new zealand because
i think that there was a major that
happened
earlier this year or late last year
um and i don't know if they vote each
other that would have been interesting
to see so
i don't know who's got the edge i don't
know
who you don't have any favorites i i got
my bias meters going crazy because these
are my guys right everybody that i know
here i've got an opinion right but
you're like i'm
okay you know more about these players
that i right and if you remember
the hard scenario if you're a tin man
only made of numbers zeros ones
and all the information the statistics
of the internet who do you give this
victory to
wowza
wowser to watch i'm a machine quick
result
okay yeah we're about to find out wowzer
versus natural the gin's been doing a
lot of work but we've been seeing a lot
of elisa let's see who this goes to
this is the loser
natural's only got six wins on that
account there's even playing gin i don't
even know at this point i don't know
what to believe man
that's only ranked matches though right
that's those are only the right
versus battles versus battles oh versus
battles oh okay okay yeah yeah
oh batman
gets the back to one and still got the
tailspin and instantly goes back to the
wall
damn a lot of back and forth getting
finally is here
let's see if we can carry him to the
next wall oh yeah does this stage
blocks the sprinklers in the spring
he connects
okay a little bit more defensive nice
side stepping a little bit late on the
response
oh oh damn yo what's up counter goes for
the charger
oh you should have did something bigger
like a can can kick so that actually
catches the low the five points you know
who cares
you know he dropped off he just wanted
for the family
you got to believe that's why you need
two cans bro
you got to be a good neighbor bring one
for you and one for them
oh while space oh guys
oh that's a huge health lead
whoa big counter here
and this is actually a back to a first
or two match yeah just for the those
watching yeah yeah
yo natural bounce wait a minute not done
yet yo the triple chain song
saw the four four threes from natural
gold we do a lot in earlier games gets
the hell sweet this time
oh four four four getting
the shot down
everything hit that's going to be the
first game for natural and hit you with
a back to one just to let you know it
ain't even over yet
that's pretty crazy he really don't like
had deep control of that whole match
just he's dominating dude he's doing
good
i like it i like it
i shouldn't have cursed wowza by saying
that it was my pick oh damn yeah see now
look at you
crazy man yeah
i'm on the air
it happens to look it happens now this
is when we get the true the true petro
rose feelings now you're like you know
what
that was a guy never liked this alisa
anyway i'm like hold on man on this kid
yo it's 50 50. it's actually 50 50.
really it's about 61 000 61 thousand
channel points one wowser it's sixty one
thousand point nine
oh wow on natural it's sixteen thousand
point seven so you guys are pretty down
the line right now right down the middle
for who you believe is gonna take to set
here man once again just for you guys
this is the tekken online challenge
oceania is on the map we got two players
here that have clawed their way clawed
their way through this tournament still
alive trying to make it to losers final
and this is a best of three so if you
trying to stay alive you gotta win i
don't know who's gonna win it though man
wowser or natural
the infinite stage good choice
let's see
oh damn just responding directly
yo natural with the seven wins we've
seen this gin a couple of times in a
turn
oh yeah
damn he's got his mid pressure on point
right now
oh wow nice dark with that stuff
hey that was calculated
let's go sleep
oh nice get the hard spike
with that while standing once yeah
damn dude naturals killing it
two rounds away
wow they both whiff yo that's sad
why explosive hook fist right there
oh double whiff
four four four another nice counter here
damn there it is nice side stepping the
hop kick
let's see he has to get a lot of damage
out of this he can't skim on this it
resets on his scaling getting some sick
damage getting whiffed on and load it
damn taking that round
match point right now for natural
wowzer really needs to kick it into gear
it needs to give yourself a three-round
turnaround
this is oh
whoa
big slide
i skipped him in check
damn don't get near me son
away from me
damn
just let you know
don't get in my way bro
um very interesting
well that's a
quite a shock one more regardless
quite a showing
regardless
um wowzer
but not the worst but still uh natural
looking way too good with the gin man
with the gin right now
yeah yeah not even like we're seeing
like these crazy combos we're not seeing
like this complete shutdown but i feel
like just using simple strings back to
one one two three one two four and just
mixing in an electric and a hail sweep
every now and then and llrk every now
and then and just not too many moves to
you know keep the meta fresh but really
just keep rotating through those rules
is really keeping wilder in check
okay yeah the standings right now
so we've got dion gray on top we've got
extra men with 145
yagami 46
roger dodger 45
and we've got subject 36 that was 35
bobby 26 and families died took over 21.
um yeah so i think
yeah i think uh the bix
also
also yeah before we go any further can
y'all make some noise osan is in the
chat right now i really hope y'all make
some noise for old son in the chat i
hope you're doing well bro yo i really
hope you're doing well i can't wait to
come back to this ticket
yeah we're talking about ulsan uh with
uh bam right last time we saw him at bam
he was doing some crazy stuff back then
that was uh that was quite the grand
final
oh yeah uh olson definitely one of the
heavy hitters out there in the world
attacking but yeah man we're getting to
this losers finals at this point uh it
will be first to three and only one
person is going to make it back to those
grand finals but all of you guys can get
yourselves one of these good ass tekken
shirts all you got to do is use the qr
code or just head on over to 10 0 uh
merch if you would like to get it
10-0.gg
merch if you would like to get your very
own that's good as tekken and with law
king nina paul we got some devil jens on
the website as well if you want to check
those out and if you want to get cutesy
with it that cute ass tekken
is just as good you can get the leroy
and sugar you can get julia you can get
the sisters nina and anna as well as
king and armor king if you guys would
like to look cool like to have some good
aztec and not only in contr in in your
controllers or in your hands but on your
body all you got to do is head on over
to 10-0 man if you guys would like to
get a shirt of your very own and let
them know i sent you
and yeah
i'm gonna send you over to my boy petro
rose so he can tell you about the
socials
yo if you want to know what's up in the
b world and the tekken sphere hey tekken
is available no matter where you are
okay twitter we've got twitter slash b
esports twitter
tekken and of course on twitch as you're
watching right now don't forget to hit
follow subscribe if you want to support
us at tekken and of course youtube if
you want to catch the vods from any
event from bandai namco esports you go
to b esports at youtube and of course
if you're on the facey you might as well
check out some tekken news go to
facebook.com take it
so yeah dude we got all the options
taken care of
and
right now we've got a couple matches to
go
so if we get geared up let's take a
break let's rehydrate have a tim tam or
whatever you need to do get your glucose
up again and we'll see use in a couple
minutes okay but don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
so
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the
tarnished
will soon return
guided by grace
once lost
the golden order is broken
to its core
[Music]
[Music]
foul
tarnished
in search of the elden ring
emboldened by the flame of ambition
someone must extinguish
thy flame
they will fight
and they will die
in an unending curse
power is a champion
or a lord
to be born
well
a lowly tarnished
playing as a lord
i command thee
brandish the elden ring
[Music]
for all of us
it's not just our power
it's all about powers working as a team
don't underestimate me
here goes
[Applause]
be prepared for anything
we have to work together
[Music]
[Applause]
focus
connect your minds and become one
use the red strings to save the world
you two handle the front while i take it
back
don't bother resisting i will obtain the
red strings
[Music]
[Music]
everyone
they're gone
we came to save you
you won't be getting out of here alive
even the smallest of sparks can grow
into an inferno i must give precedence
to the task at hand snuffing out your
fire before it spreads across the five
those with power set the example
and those without it are forced to obey
i found you at last and i see you came
along as well
dannon witch
i thought i had been doomed to a life of
solitude that doesn't mean i'm going to
stop looking out for you not now not
ever
[Music]
everyone be careful
that
[Music]
[Music]
and the renaissance
looks like we've got our work cut out
for us
welcome back everybody the tekken online
challenge oceania is on the map and
that's what you're watching that's one
of the reasons we got the homie petro
rose with his own commentary or i should
say i'm joining you on commentary how
have how have the matches been on your
side of things yo
fire man they're really good lots of
upsets big upsets i wasn't expecting but
happy that they were there because it
just adds that drama of how it going to
conclude like right now i don't have a
clear plan as to how things are going to
finish because
all my expectations got knocked out like
i don't even know what to think anymore
it's going to be really interesting to
see how things conclude
so yeah i'm all in well i'm glad i'm
glad that you're still with us one of
the people one of the groups oh yeah i'm
happy that are still with us also it's
astro man the official headset and mix
amp of the tekken online challenge and
just of fgc of old as well as new man
and i'm sure a lot of people have some
overlap with astro so shout outs to
astro for being so given to the world of
the fgc and even some of the people a
lot closer to you and around the way oh
yeah definitely
so yeah like
astro has been like integral in the
support of the australian fgc for the
past year and two years i guess since
the
since the you know the lockdowns have
really kicked in and we're doing
basically online related stuff ash was
like yeah we got you and they've been
supporting couch warriors bam every time
they come around and just generally the
the local
uh australian fgc has been kept afloat
from ashrae support which is huge huge
so yeah we're really grateful for their
support as i said the patron saints of
the s especially tekken fgc they've been
they've been uh you know holding us back
you know holding supporting us for years
now so yeah it's always always good
every time i see ashram like the other
that's good you know and they're always
around let's check the brackets okay so
win aside we've got yagami pushing his
way through winners to the grand final
undefeated
and in losers side we have
natural
winning through this match with wowzer
going to the losers final against
excrement so extra mint and natural are
going to fight in the losers final first
of three match see who's going to get
their chance at a match against yagami
they have to you know get the reset and
then do it all over again to claim first
place let's see let's find out one step
at a time we've got a loser's final to
check out let's see how it's gonna play
out
extreme and natural trying to get back
to grand finals like you pointed out
they're gonna need to win no matter who
it is they're still gonna need to win
two sets if they actually want to get
the championship point and get the lion
shed at 300 big point added bonus to
your points for the region you gotta get
first place you gotta reset it if you
want to get first place i should say so
it's not gonna be easy no matter what
yeah yeah yeah for sure now it's all
down to the wire man the big three let's
see what that's going to play out
i wonder what characters we're going to
probably going to see the gin we're
going to see from natural legend xiaoyu
unless maybe like extra man's feeling
like oh man i just lost let me try
something else
personally i wouldn't if i was you know
i'll i hope not as well he's the xiaoyu
is
pretty red-hot it's really really good
so there's no reason to like just start
doubting yourself at this point and
start picking other characters
so unless he's got some mega plan i was
like you know and you know gin versus
xiao it's like a low battle dude that's
pretty good so
you know it's the honeymoon periods over
it's been over six months at this point
now now we're getting into conflict
where you know the true the true
relationship starts to begin you know
what i'm saying
okay
shout out to the ship is out yeah the
real low battles dude
bro the shippers are strong out here bro
they got their own little threads and
everything bro got whole story's in the
whole nine
but here we go
what's up three guys
oh yeah this is man infinite azure this
is first to three first to three for
this last set on the loser side of
things to see who's gonna make it to
grand finals here we go
oh there's that four four three gets the
back three just to get the combo too
takes the op
oh
that's the one electric bro
nice block nice standing four
again extra men trying to get around him
but he just has that nice hook fist man
it's hard to get around
damn corpse bashing bro
[Music]
wow nice out of the roll
combo does get scaled a lot and it
wasn't like a finish but still
that means getting that pressure doesn't
give a damn
okay a little bit defensive from uh
natural
gets hit hey rolls out of that okay
returns to pressure
i like that option
to stay on the ground too
yeah yeah that's smart smart
oh well
this could be giga brain no i was
knocking a brain i'm like is he saying
something i'm not nah
nah
yeah fishing right there trying to find
something big
the lull's starting to add up once again
back turn aop scoring a lot of hits
[Music]
i'll kick again down four
back to one
just maintaining his buttons
making the conversions
and actually tried to make that count
with the back three
axe that's just the startup of aop is
that what happened he just did it
right there hey
bruh
right on the beat that was sick
uh we do that's how we do it here dude
we're tas you know see
nice nice even if we check mars magic
wall that should close it if you place
it right okay no the steam is in that's
right watch out oh my god
okay blocking the blue stuff denying it
that's it
natural taking that first one pretty
solid pretty solid um look
extra mint tried to fight back gotta he
got one piece but not enough not enough
i think that like uh naturals on a tear
like he's the past few matches we've
seen he knocked dion gray he knocked a
friendly tree he knocked wowzer like god
give the guy this medal man he already
like won three finals already just to
get here it's like okay okay relax you
know now he's just still going at it so
it's pretty good to see him like
maintain pace
and it seems like natural was really
starting to pick up pace like it's
really starting to become like a
snowball kind of effect where like even
though he's not doing like these crazy
instances he's not getting like a crazy
amount of damage but just keeping that
momentum in his favor especially versus
a character like xiao yu who is known
wants to start feeling once she starts
feeling herself if you're a player and
you're feeling yourself with jiao you
you really start to go crazy with the
offense with the buttons not to the
point where you're going to get launched
or anything there it is we did see the
hop kick workout but not so much
especially now that we're getting a
complete character switch with the lily
oh yeah that's his tgo like despite uh
xiaoyu being his main he's been popping
the lily recently and he's getting mad
results and you know all and also
getting our tgo rank which is really
hard in oc which is a smaller region but
it's hard to get as many matches to get
that you know how many billion of
matches you have to get to get that rank
so yeah they managed to pull it off with
a lily yeah yeah
and we didn't talk about the size of the
limits in the world right oh yeah that's
bad
100 100 yeah yeah
so the match-up knowledge is being
tested but you know
i feel like everyone at this level
already does know it like you know
to be a player of this caliber you kind
of know your matchups at this point well
i heard the electric didn't see it
though
i don't
oh yeah
okay how's it gonna close in okay a
little kick
there's another one oh goes for the
triple no good that's the low power you
should carry him to the wall right now
pretty comfortably
oh does not stick okay
oh wow extra man
and close it with a rager beautiful
[Music]
[ __ ] now he's gonna sit and watch that
yep
round three give him something to think
about natural ties up the second game
one round gets the back three but no
combo
oh big counter puts him up
good carry lily has very good carry not
only are the side steps something you
need to be worried about but her wall
carry if she actually gets a launcher
oh okay
god the side will save lives man
oh my goodness
okay this is extra men's chance okay
ducks there the [ __ ] fist
doesn't get a chance to punish it
down oh counter
takes the okie i like that in the open
stage just take the okie that way you
get to keep the pressure wait a minute
though not able to make anything happen
from that big launcher
extra man with the lily actually has the
round lead and the life lead
oh you're dead
bringing it back times up the set and
losers final one game apiece
that is clean that is very clean look at
that man extra mint he's got it man he
knows what's up so that that was very
good that was very good so now this
seems to be a more interesting match
before i was feeling like
this could be like potentially like a
natural could have just produced a
blowout and just get all three but now
it's coming back and forth and the lily
pick bang it worked i was like okay i'm
listening i'm listening like he could
hold that character for the whole match
at this point yeah
were you expecting like the switch to
lily
uh a little bit i was like okay if he's
gonna make a change it's now or never at
this point because the first three match
he has to like pull it out like i knew
that he had a pocket lily because he
depends sometimes he'll turn up to a
tournament just with lily and that's it
and he'll still get you know top plays
so you know but
usually the pattern is like if it's
serious if he's really going for it the
xiao you is what usually dominates
that's why i was not you know shocked
when he pulled that out okay he's going
all in but now it looks like he's xiaoyu
has been not serving him properly in
these matchups why not try the lily at
this point you know he's got the skills
and it's working out for him so yeah
let's give it a go
all right still in a race to see who's
going to get back to this grand finals
from loser's side
twilight conflict
oh
we're doing general outpost or
hey jungle outfits let's go oh my bad
that's it twilight complex geez my bad
oh that's all right that was so good man
so good
god
takes him at the wall
trying to keep him in place
look at that don't be ducking that
oh he tries to catch
seems like he's in naturals head right
now
against the wall while standing four
two four and the balcony break back turn
come on
let's go
damn okay okay natural on the way to
take a lead now starting strong with the
hook fist
to get the wall pretty comfortably right
in the corner actually even better for
himself can can not
yeah keeping him in check trying to
prevent her from like lateral movement
that's all right
breaking yeah
okay
okay who's gonna approach first going
with that health sweep
[Music]
natural slowing the pace of that last
round was down to a crawl and then you
saw guy really like picky with some of
the options he started to go for
especially on block seeing how like
reactionary that lily was playing right
there and knows that she can size up
super well so i like just the jabs check
to see if there was going to be a side
step that's one of the reasons that the
matterhorn didn't hit right didn't get
anything big from it but that would have
been the round and that could have been
something else you would have that that
would have been another round you would
have had the win to get that match so i
like playing slowing it down a little
bit jab check with the side step to see
if anything is going to happen didn't
get the punish once again but just the
fact that you was able to bait it out
let you know that you're on the right
thought process with the
meta but yeah dude this is looking very
interesting now now let's make or break
for extra mint it did so well to get
through to with a side and now it's he's
risking losing it all you know again
third place ain't bad i ain't gonna lie
so but you know yeah you want the you
know what the big w dude yeah yeah i'm
messing around going with the mishima
dojo interesting pick well actually a
good it's a pretty solid pick to be
honest
let's see has once again great wall
carry and just the fact that now you're
committed to you no matter what win or
lose if you win this round you're still
stuck with lilly you still can't switch
anyway yeah so you've committed yeah
oh the root of all evil
oh yeah
keeping him in place
it's a solid round start right now
massive health lead
four four actually the four four three
and twenty rounds watching up real quick
back to one
didn't even need to rewall the line gets
the
dead
wow
wow
holy moly okay
electric you know what's coming that was
the warning
well i'm standing four
oh there it is
getting the wall splat
how's gonna keep him in place
wow natural going deep right now going
deep into the move list
four four yeah
back three clutches clinching the the
mental alertness one plus two gets the
launch this is set point your extreme
needs something big right now needs this
round to begin with can't actually lose
any more rounds at this point or you're
out of here get this match you got one
more game to play but
oh counter heads damn this kind of hits
yeah there's
no mercy yeah naturals ability to keep
extreme in place is really strong
despite wow
you got to be kidding me
no round brown to close it off whoa
ow this guy
that yeah imagine going out like that
rip dude that was insane
dude natural
killing it moving into the grand final
his chance to actually
get the first spot because he didn't
make it through uh winner's side top
eight so now he's now he isn't winning
side top eight who would have thought
well so now all he needs to get that
reset
so an extra minute of course killer
performance made it all the way to third
place giving himself 150 points on top
of the 145 that he has that means he has
like 295
he's already a winner in everybody's
eyes dude he's five points away from
winning this whole damn thing in points
so hey he's guaranteed a position pretty
much for the
the regional finals so now his job now
is the training montage okay this is the
training arc for extra mint so by
december it's going to be jacked okay so
i'm ready to watch it dude so you know
we're going to be doing tournaments here
in oc best time to practice turn up to
your
turn up to your local online tournaments
do what you got to do and get your reps
in man so yeah you got some opportunity
you have some opportunities to enter for
your respective regions still korea and
japan up next of course the regional
final events all listed there starting
in november will end early next year in
n a if you guys want to check it out
remember this is for your respective
regions west europe east europe japan
south east asia south asia philippines
central america south america west
africa you guys are all there we're
starting off with south africa when it
comes to those regional events and if
you would like to submit your own
application you got to do it by october
10th if you want to be included in one
of these dojos make sure you sign up
asap and potentially you can have a dojo
event just by signing up and if you want
to sign up to play make sure you head on
over to that esports tekken portal tech
and dash esports dot bn-ent dot ent
forward slash if you would like to sign
up remember submissions will end october
8th so get in now and that way you can't
say you didn't know
oh yeah man that's it like
you can't say we didn't tell you like
pretty much we can't you can't say we
didn't tell you dude we'll let you know
all women
i always say they'll be like bro i
didn't see it you're gonna get somebody
gonna come in the chat like 10 minutes
from now and be like bro when are the
other ones taking place look if you go
back and watch the vod they're littered
all throughout you get the dates you get
the times you get the regions
you should have been paying attention
i'm just kidding and if not you know you
could just check any one of the socials
to make sure that you're up to date
socials are
what we're getting and also like it's
very likely that you could ask probably
your like favorite tech and streamer
usually keeps up with this stuff more
than likely you just ask them you know
you know what's up they'll hit you up or
someone some like giga brain twitch chat
because we know that twitch chat
is like the smartest people as like a
bio-organism it's like they like the
borg right but they're always right the
smartest the best of the game we don't
know what we're talking about but they
do you can always ask someone in chat
they'll give you though he sent me the
hyperlinks okay you click and it takes
you straight there they're ready dude
they're they're ready to help always at
all times
yeah speaking of those links and taking
us there bro just hit this qr
qr code
or you can hit this merge code uh head
on over to 10-0 you guys can get some
good ass taken or some cute ass taking
shirts man the twins the kings leroy or
julia in that cute ass tekken are you
can get law you can get king you can get
paul as well as nina as well and your
respective good ass tekken shirts man
head on over to 10 0 if you would like
to get your very own
yeah man and what's coming up we think
we got the grand finale right the big
one let's see who's
dude i want to see the predictions for
this one okay i want to see what people
think are we gonna get the reset are we
gonna get you know is it gonna be a
blowout what are we gonna do so oh and
more importantly
let's uh let's say that the grand final
is between melbourne for australia
and um new zealand so new zealand and
australia have made it to the grand
final that the whole oceanic region is
covered yeah from top to bottom okay
so you can't say you know we didn't do
it right so that's pretty good i
actually like that i like that all right
so pastor rose let me let me ask the
chat you stay out of this i want to see
what how the chat feels a disabled
character
tell me i'm not going to look the same
so who i want to know
is going to take this who's going to is
it going to be new zealand
is that who takes this
chat let me know
which part of your respected oceanic
region is about to take this grand
finals that you guys are about to watch
this is a first to three a reset is
needed if you're coming from the loser's
side but if not
it's going to go straight to melbourne i
don't know who's going to take it bro
yo the chat's going crazy right now
i trust chat okay i don't need to look
at it i know what's up
damn chat
are they making some noise though that's
what i want
the chance
i
give me a one for melbourne give me a
two for new zealand if you really about
it let me see the numbers in the chat a
one for melbourne or two for new zealand
and big hooks coming in no barely any
damage being deal
oh damn i got a number
there goes the numbers
lots of tunes in there lots of ones
though
all right here we go grand finals
underway
there we go
the chat is [ __ ] up
in check
make sure they put the predictions in as
well
i'm looking at him right now
oh yeah
okay a lot of a little bit of exposure
from yagami
wow just ducking into that evil intent
from natural okay yeah
is this giga brain or what's going on i
have no idea
yeah this is a little bit interesting
but jin has moves to hit on the ground
bro so i'm pretty sure
yeah yeah hey perfect round that's not
bad
all right let's see what that was the
beginning of the round to tell us
yeah that's the holding down yeah
oh probably just waiting right now
i like the respect though i will say
that i do like the respect though yeah
yeah
until we're verified of the situation
he's pad broke
yeah
wow
bro that sucks cause i'm gonna tell you
right now that ain't got nothing to do
with me i'ma just be real oh yeah
they ain't got nothing to do if you're
okay i'm gonna tell you
i got out of this my hands are actually
clean from this i got not no
the technical difficulties they got
nothing to do
with who you think is gonna win that
just sounds like
that's fate right there bro you might
you might be going into this
with a losing streak because the
controller decided to crap out but
that's fate that just means you really
need to want to win if you actually take
it back from this instance
damn uh this is this is actually i don't
think that's ever happened to me
from memory have you ever had like a
control a pad breakdown no but pads are
red they're like really yeah either it's
very rare
and i've been playing i'm telling you
right now there's i've been playing
video games for a long time and if when
it comes to tournament i've never
i have never
and i'm an arcade stick player so i've
always bought my own controller
and even if i did have to borrow
somebody else's arc i've it's never been
like boo like it's never like not worked
on me so
yeah yeah but it does happen i think it
definitely happens
yeah i think the only case i can
remember is like when dion's fight stick
like he has like those you know these
top level players how they have these
like frankenstein believers that don't
even tell you what components are in
them yes right proprietary switches and
blah blah blah and then like they go to
the tournament and it craps the bed and
it's only going up and they're like hey
panther can you give me your stock done
while eva that works and i'm like no
here it is
look
you think i'll say no because i'm the
bad guy you know i'm the heel right now
but i'm telling you when the when we get
difficult
bro it's the good cop backpack game you
know
i always do that i'm gonna tell you know
so somebody else can tell you yeah you
know and it's just
but you're right though you're
definitely right though
but you know
you got to take care of your equipment
or you have to i don't know having a
backup that's pretty tough that's hard
you know if you're at home
you have like five controls or something
dude you know i'm gonna tell you right
now if the controller crap out before
the round starts back up i'm gonna have
a new controller in like that's how many
controllers i have yeah and my now my
controller historically don't crap out
on me whether and i don't use anything
outside of a fighting arcade stick for
most of the stuff that i use oh yeah
yeah 100 yeah
and that's all right i'm lucky man yeah
that's okay
i'm assuming he'll be fine he'll have
something some
solutions yeah
if this if you're actually a pad player
i'm going to tell you right now right i
don't use pad that much for
uh anything but like even for my ps5
before i had my ps5 i had already an
extra controller and even though i don't
play fighting games on said controller
if i'm playing yeah yeah anything if i'm
playing elden ring when it drops if my
controller goes out in the middle of
that battle is gonna shut down a second
and i'm gonna have a literally i have it
on the box behind it's in a box behind
me so yeah yeah
dude i legit have like over there i've
got like ps2 controllers in their
plastic casing from greece like with
greek on it i've got two of them or
something because the other ones i got i
i keep
look they're like 15 years old sitting
there but they're ready okay anything
happens in a little you know we're
playing like tekken 5 or something you
know on the ps2 hey we got the backups
at all times we don't you never skim
down on the backups no that's definitely
serious business dude i'm i was one of
those guys i tell people all the time
like i wish my friends that i like
played video games with growing up would
tell you like i was the dude who bought
the multi-tap i had the extra
controllers
i was the homie that gave you that extra
controller that you needed at the last
second bro but anyways we're back in
here this is a first step back in
business
awesome no reset yet for those who just
jumped in so they just
started yeah one round but yagami on
winner's side and then uh naturals on
loser's side
[Music]
oh down back four back to the pokes and
the power crush yeah you have to
backtech right there or you get a free
shoe shine
while standing for natural
playing the neutral and another power
track you gotta duck those you gotta
duck those damn
brave enough
there we go
of course you got me
on winner's side
so natural has to win
two sets
if he hopes to actually run this back
oh not stepping trying to evade the
stance but
about to make a decision to go in on oh
shoeshine getting denied
wow
breaks the stun on the counter hit right
there
yeah yeah
yeah cause if you get the back four two
counter hit it put you in the stun you
have to hit forward to break it or else
they get a free launcher it's gin
[Music]
oh power
oh
like yeah bro i know you came all the
way from loser's side i know you
traveled a long way you said you came
from another continent that's good news
bro but i might send you back without
losing without me losing around i'm not
trying to lose i like it
i'm actually glad that
um yagami didn't get phased you know
because usually when you have a
technical malfunction that will throw
you off your game pretty bad like you
feel this pressure it's like i'm
screwing things up what's wrong
um and i was actually worried i'm like
this could be a big advantage for
natural but just because of like a
mishap it's like nothing technical um
but no like yagami came back with a
vengeance and i'm like okay he's still
in it and it looks like naturals uh run
is going to be really hard he has to be
he has to be getting his wins every time
he's got
unlimited stamina he needs to just get
it done
so to go back and forth pre-reset is
pretty tough no matter how you put it
let's see where they're gonna choose
yeah
yeah yeah
so let's see um if he's gonna pick a
stage that he prefers or i don't think
there's gonna be a character change to
be honest
yeah okay
running it back okay okay
still natural has to win the next two
games
at least all right it's gonna be a done
deal already natural has fought pretty
long and hard to get back to this point
so i know he ain't trying to go on like
that but here we go
there we go trying to apply some
pressure but man y'all can be just
ducking at all
oh four
back three on the float
still gets the wall savage axe for the
ender shout out to my bro mark man
oh nice
they keeping that chip
wow
legit got over the down four right there
but wait a minute natural takes that
first round
oh
natural trying to mess with his timing a
little bit trying to throw him off but
oh good old denied again
[Music]
i think he let the second hit rip so
even though he committed to it that
means he would have been in trouble
spins the blue early yagami trying to
close out this round but natural a hit
away from closing at the slow mo
devastating how like quick it is
it doesn't do much damage but god dammit
can it end the round for you like it's
really crazy
there we go big jump knees
back to the low pulse natural got a
chance right now yeah yeah
there you go
folks oh he's going he's got a pretty
good low poke
i mean you're not stepping start a 4-4
counter hit natural but drops the combo
power crush
spins the blue early that's good for
natural up 4-2 counter hit blocks for
low
bounce
actually got the wall bounce but did the
wrong combo thought that elisa was right
next to the wall ah
that that's that's devastating yeah that
could that can throw you off more than
the controller dying
yeah
oh yeah
see what the decision is going to be now
so that's what a piece right
so one game back and forth back and
forth yeah yeah
so that means we're gonna throwing at
least you know getting some kind of
momentum is really good that way you can
potentially drag the games out you said
that natural was tired too right but
natural's been fighting naturally being
warmed up fighting through this loser
side right and if you look at it
alisa
been kind of cooled off so now you can
turn up that offense a little bit see
how awake they are at the wheel you know
you gotta i feel like it's one of those
things where you do want to play safe
but you also got to see where the
openings are because they're just as
tired as you are
maybe even more yeah it's a double-edged
sword yeah yeah
okay infinite
wants that space i don't believe scenic
that's
suiting up
damn don't get in my way
oh fight
guess what he starts off gonna get in
your way
oh nice nice oh
wait a minute
nice standard standard operation yo
oh boy
don't be spring kicking what are you
doing
oh wow a little bit off axis there
didn't get the hit with the chainsaw
yeah yeah rage wow
really wow
wow
had the hit but didn't believe
one twos
simple pressure here to try to start a
bigger game
natural
with the life lead now
wow oh my god it goes right underneath
it didn't get some massive punish for it
equal health really for what's
considered
okay okay but if you remember that's the
exact same thing that yagami did last
time and natural duck and launched it
nice you can even check naturals always
just one step ahead there you go
shutting down those chainsaws
oh two on four
okay
there's the hell sweep
as he's gonna approach it go to the
stomp misses
okay finishes the two on four didn't get
anything from it this time the downfall
one's just a poke that game is adding up
natural
with the lead
yagami turns on the off oh
challenges
yeah that was a good challenge plenty of
health to take the risk
oh my god oh god no chill no chill
and natural playing like he's right in
yagami's living room
like he's knocking on the bedroom door
like hey what are you doing
oh wait a minute
very nice
reset yo we've seen that before actually
goes for the while standing two gets the
hit oh watch out okay restart
opportunities
oh my god they're back to one they don't
want to get in one actually gets through
one match away from the reset natural
damn what are the votes
we have um
oh
second where the book
okay so we've got 57 for natural for the
re for the reset but they're believing
they're believing
so we've got 134k that's a lot of points
that's no joke damn
okay okay
let's see if it's gonna play out
natural one game away from the reset
though
with the gym
and i think it's just because he's
not afraid to check in a lot of
instances down four ones the down fours
just to like keep stagger long enough
for you to be like all right what am i
gonna do next what happens next i really
like that coming from natural and
starting to even go further into that
gym move this we saw the one the four
three three just to look for the block
stun but we also saw like the back dash
so you can tell that you know thinking
about playing a lot slower down the line
cool
now
it should be getting ready now let's see
oh there it is boom
let's see what kind of adaptation we're
gonna see i don't know
yeah i think that um yeah there's no
risk
oh he's just going straight back
at the same time i can't really blame
him
yeah because it feels like
it feels like natural is really starting
to get like a feel for some of these
like for these games and it's just clean
in some instances if it keeps up this
way i'm not i would not be surprised by
a reset round one
yeah yeah yeah he's definitely in a zone
at this point
that very comfortable just playing the
same kind of pattern oh look at that wow
that's tough that's tough
how's it gonna take his approach going
low you shine
he's zipping in nice nice push and pull
there wave a wave
oh yeah
okay
i like that didn't commit all the way to
it
knows that natural is looking for it
counter hit down back four and once
again the same situation uses the blue
stuff catches him blinking and drops the
combo
oh my god natural on his way two more
rounds and we gotta reset
oh okay punishable
[Music]
trying to close the gap
kind of plays a little pressure trying
to get out of yagami's range
they can get some sweet counter hit
action but kind of hard
because look man yagami's pushing and
pulling as well he's got especially the
chainsaws
so stressful once they're out
to not get buffed by him oh the
realignment
okay natural
behind in health but it looks like he's
got the the mental uh plus right now
you got me trying to slow this down now
your gummy trying to slow this down now
wow gets the counter hit on the one two
four
okay
oh my god
and just the down four goes into
chainsaw mode
yeah he's giving him the chance to kind
of like hide himself and looking for
whip punishes you got me in trouble and
instantly always the minute yagami has
gotten rage always start they just spin
the blue stuff instantly
spring up bring back oh almost
want some patience on the wake up
one three three there is exactly what
i'm talking about starting to go further
into the moveless one round away from
the reset mattress
you're tearing the legs up
beautiful low parry
oh nice i almost got a little reset
there no good
power crush once again natural slowing
down the offense the defense excuse me
starting the double eyes
yeah let's change those wow big lateral
movements getting serious amounts of
damage four four
trying to make this interesting by
resetting the grand finals and now
yagami is on the ropes now we're back at
zero now it's the first to three wins
we'll be our champion here
we're getting a full length tournament
right now okay we're getting there
you'll getting every bit of every bit of
matches we can pull out of this we're
getting it all we're getting the resets
now now is where it really matters i
want to see how it's going to play out
everybody's been has lost once okay
but only one guy can stay that way so
let's see how it's going to play out i'm
very interested i'm actually
really impressed not like it's
unexpected but like damn like it's some
serious as we discussed earlier like
natural went through so many people that
could have classified as grand finalists
and you said that you did what you said
then
and then as you said like this guy just
got warmed up and put into a zone
instead of getting tired he's like
almost in a trance at this point where
he's just like going just throw me
another match another match another
match and he's just another
another another
i wanna win give me another one but it's
two at least you beat two elizabeth i
don't care give me another one i want
the points all three hundred we don't
have anyone in australia all right
so yeah this is gonna end up pretty
enough
yeah though this is very interesting
though the fact that natural is bringing
this back with the gin and it's it's i
i'm it's very very like simple game plan
play like yo i'm gonna hit you with this
one two three if you swing i'm gonna get
a free down too you freeze up these down
back fours come out and natural just
really has a rhythm to his game right
now but you can slowly you can slowly
tell what's happening with elisa yagami
is learning what exactly gin is trying
to do in a lot of these instances
especially coming from natural and it's
slow adjustments happening but i feel
like if natural doesn't close us out
soon yagami might start getting wind of
what's happening
oh oh nice denied him
alright so surprisingly enough this
pressure is doing good stuff
oh nice size stepping over here it's
actually a launcher
okay change oh no wolf about it now two
four could have been a lot worse
oh wow double low
fight
damn yagami's like cranked off the
intensity scale
the thing is though you can tell that
yagami
is kind of at width and at some of these
situations because natural is just a
little more offensive right like he's
really taking it to him right now
four four three and one
game plan
game plan
natural dude through loser's side one
two three one you swing on the three the
one's gonna juggle you get a free tail
spin off of that
[Music]
trying to create an opportunity for
himself no good see nacho just keeps him
in check and then forces him to have to
actually block and he gets whacked with
the hell sweep almost every time
with the red dress
using chainsaws go straight back to the
low like just about even slight lead in
favor of natural right
wow okay okay okay
now y'all got me ahead now
lots of four four down back four
pressure and now you got me starting to
poke he's like you know what i'm not
gonna keep letting you get away with
just poking me with this up close game
gets the while standing too
sidewalk and not being able to make
anything big happen from it
damn another hell sweep damn a lot of
these laws are connecting is like
it's like yagami is like unwilling to
yield to start ducking because he can
get caught up in so many overheads
but it's just a mess like like how can
he maintain his game
okay chainsaws helps
ah just out of range better range
one more round left in his first match
of the reset
oh charging up doesn't give it a full
get sidestepped
oh oh wow it zips out of that one
let's keep him in check goes in the zen
stance no good
big block right there
giving himself a serious combo oh okay
resets for the shoe shine goes to the
hop kick gets pulled that's it he gets
the first point he falls good ends good
there you go yagami taking the first
point of this reset of the grand finals
here in the second
online challenge for 2021 in oceania god
damn
back and forth back and forth
the hard kick to save it
okay
but this is what i was talking about
though now you can see it's not that
natural is slowing down but you can
definitely tell that the understanding
of the you know the process the moves
that are being used they're really
starting to take his toll and now you
see a list of like oh i'm just gonna
down jab i'm gonna put a four here yeah
just taking away the poke game the down
fours the one two threes yeah are not as
pivotal now you're not seeing a lot of
four four you're not even seeing the
standing fours anymore and it's because
of the movement uh alyssa alisa is
playing at that range now or 4-4 is a
tool but if you're not getting that he's
going to walk around you and you're
seeing it happen a lot over and over now
it's up to natural to make an adjustment
if you really want to keep this lead if
you really want to keep that momentum or
get the momentum back right now you
gotta stop
so let's see um
i really doubt it's gonna change
character honestly
because he's like another guy that like
when things get a bit hairy he'll like
start considering that like you start
like saying maybe the character can fix
the situation
but i would say he should stick to it
and there he is good stuff going mashima
building trying to pin up um
yagami try and keep him into corners
provide like you know produce the wall
is another
scenario that you have to consider and
another level of pressure that gin is
really good with like sticking against
the wall he can really put your brain in
a blender so let's see if we can
turn the tables right now by providing
some walls
they've been doing so many infinite
stages lately this one this is like a
change of pace
there you go big pressure
down four
and really and now you see the pace
just start to slow down now
offense get a little more visible for
yagami right now counter hit 4-4 just as
i say that coming from a natural in the
gym
waltz black oh but the drop drops
right there
nice block
oh
and look at this and now you see natural
starting to readjust we break the
oneplus 2
oh my god
this is oh my god
that jab is deadly oh my god and he's
like letting him remember it's like yeah
yeah yeah
but you see what i was talking about
though the down jab is really stopping
at up close pressure
natural in trouble
staggering the offense a little bit
blocks the low
oh big whiff okay minor punish
oh they are okay i'll sweep that's
pretty good
okay this is a bit of a stalemate over
here oh my god not anymore
man you got me turning around you ran
right into
[Music]
and it's really put natural in a bad
situation he's really not comfortable
dealing with this pace to listen
down 4-1 to stop that pressure
let's the second hit rip wait a minute
what a duck okay wait a minute
oh man
this could be a tough spot
there's a splat okay
oh
oh are you still in it he's still in it
he's still in it
okay natural getting himself his first
round
all right power crush this time no duck
oh denial perry definitely gonna get the
wall now this pressure right now for
yagami has been really strong wow
this time chase is the special get up
he'll sweep wait a minute natural got
got some wheels got some traction now
downforce the down four one tries to go
for the down another one it's not gonna
work and harada cares
oh he's gonna pull the charger no he
does not
shoeshine
ready with the mojo oh my god
an absolute return come back this is
like the worst case scenario for natural
you know who cares how many horrada
cares bro he had less than a fingernails
worth the life
harada cares
that 5hp ain't gonna do nothing for me i
got a family i got kids to feed i got
tournaments to win what am i gonna do
with five extra points you better talk
to yagami yagami just did it you made it
count
but that five hp ain't wasting it on
slopes dude he putting that strength of
the s p 500 dude getting his returns
damn
around the five hp bro
that's right straight to the s p 500
damn
that's crazy
um yeah man like it's funny that today
we've seen a lot of these like you know
corrado steamies everywhere ran some
matters but this one's
[Laughter]
now is that the new is that the what's
the matter who's this is this now
it still is it's still the harada care
right it's the harada care package
yeah if you have a harada let me see him
in the chat right now let me see your
harada's in the chat if we got taste
buds up this yeah stateside let me see
your harada's in the chat i dropped mine
off just to let y'all know it's real
but here we go
really
no i this is this is what naturals this
is the stage natural likes to go to to
get control of things but yeah it's not
working and it's 2-0 right now
in this reset after natural resetting
let's see it's kind of interesting how
uh yagami took control of this reset
with a 2-0 lead
let's see okay a lot of back and forth
taking turns
nice with punish
beautiful carry nice high splat oh
damage
oh yeah big low parry not much damage
but let's see if you can get it to the
wall create a better scenario for yard
on me
oh my god yeah
challenging him with the rage driver
while standing forward low period
not enough though oh my god damn another
robber it's insane this is crazy i don't
even know what's going on anymore
he's two rounds away from taking this
whole thing man
four four
try the side sidewalk it
gets around one of them wow four four
counting
dropping legs
big saws holding them back
okay y'all got me slowing a bit let's
see oh using the armor
all denied that elsewhere finally there
you go
perfect response
tournament point right now for yagami
this could be it
one two
natural still has a chance though all
the way through losers so it's not over
just yet not over just yet but now you
see ugami really taking his time before
going in really setting the offense up
with the jabs nice read right there with
the down four one four
yeah natural shouldn't be overextending
should be like be very careful with
decisions to end up but then again that
gives yagami a lot of opportunities to
come in with the chainsaws like we're
looking at right now
he's gonna put a stop to it oh my god
the damage
no chill
oh there it is there it is had a feeling
baiting it and there it is
yagami
the champion of the tekken online
challenge 2021 for oceania masters event
300 points right to you guaranteeing
your position
into the regional finals in december
dude
very exciting and of course man one of
the maddest like losers run all the way
up into a reset by natural representing
new zealand and you know showing them
what the region's got very very good
performance
very happy to see him back with his gin
which is something i haven't seen in a
while so a lot of fun very very good uh
tournament results that i was not
expecting um it wasn't like scripted in
my mind i had a feeling that it would
have a certain flow it did not and i
loved every second of it dude very nice
very nice so first off man can y'all
make some noise in the chat for natural
what oh man i was what a tournament run
to make it all the way back through
losers two grand finals um unfortunately
not able to keep that momentum after the
reset yagami was definitely paying
attention and a lot of you guys weren't
paying attention because 86 percent of
you and 162 000 channel points went to
natural only 14
bet on yagami to take it after the reset
so somebody's rich right now somebody's
actually rich right now with these
channel points and i'm glad you guys are
excellent in there to show your love
show your appreciation for your
respective regions yo shout outs to new
zealand but melvin is gonna take it and
you can see right here with the point
update yagami with
346 points extra mint 295 dion gray with
a great tournament run 255 once again
natural making a big leap up on the
leaderboard 220 points puts him in
fourth place wowzer another great
showing at fifth place now has a hundred
500 m down there with 70 points in sixth
place we got roger dodger still there
with 70 points and of course subject
with 61 points we saw subject just not
make it just barely out of that top
eight still on that top eight
leaderboard and there's events left you
got to october 10th to sign up your
event for a dojo and potentially get
more points but the winner today will be
none other than yagami you saw it there
with the points man there's been so many
good matches today when it comes to what
we've been saying a lot of back and
forth a reset for the grand finals
potentially and man just you know
oceania holding it down out there man
you guys have been playing
this entire time i'm glad you've been
taking it
never
stopped oh yeah man like this is it man
that's all we got and we take advantage
of the opportunities we have man it's
like you can't pick or choose it's like
yo we got online tournaments we're
turning up and that's good and i'm
always happy um
throughout the year the numbers of
entries has been steadily increasing
it's not like you know it's a consistent
certain number that we're hitting all
the time and it's always getting a
little bit better every every month that
goes by i'm really happy about that that
everything's alive and well and doing
better actually seeing a lot of new
faces people crying out yeah yeah on so
one of the things that i've noticed and
i know you brought up like couch
warriors before is that like you guys
have been holding events for a very long
time um especially when it comes to not
only just like you know tekken but like
i've come out there and i've commentated
other game events as well for you know
just for the region and you guys when it
comes to the locals when it comes to the
majors when it comes to just having a
good like fgc community from what i'm
seeing man you guys are doing strong i'm
happy y'all still playing tekken i'm
really happy you guys are taking
advantage of these online tournaments
and can i just say yo check can y'all
make some noise for petrol rose for
holding it down with me all night on
this tekken online challenge i mean it's
night for me but it's it's the evening
for you guys as well it's been an honor
to break with you man it's been it's
been dope i appreciate it on the mic man
you've been holding it down for these
online regions along with brown man who
uh effectively poisoned rick with the
ten temps uh
electrically occurred allegedly
i was you know i was in the room right i
was literally sitting right next to him
when he was like i don't feel so good
i'm like is it the tim tams he's like
it's hell of the tim tams
was the tray empty yeah oh yes
he tried to he tried to offer me some
but i said no but uh let me just say
again before we get out here shout outs
to astro the official headset and mixamp
of the tekken online challenge all those
regions all those regions that you saw
that are coming up that still have
master events for their respective
regions west africa south africa
everywhere they are being supported by
astro and tekken so shout outs to astro
for being the official headset and mick
santos those a40s hold us down quite
well and it definitely helps me out on
commentary show shout outs to astro and
of course make sure you guys stay up to
date on all your tech news and be any
esports news because it's not only
tekken but you're watching take it right
now follow us on facebook twitch as well
as twitter for all tekken updates and if
you want to make sure you stay up to
date on all the esports news coming from
bandai namco make sure you give us a
follow at bne esports at both twitter as
well as youtube if you guys want to see
the videos if you can't catch the vibes
you want to know about the tournaments
that's all you got to do and that's how
we gonna see you guys at all these other
events so make sure you guys first off
show a lot of love to bandai namco for
making sure these events continue to
happen as well as just having to take an
online challenge man it's been a
pleasure and i'm trust me just like you
guys at home are watching this
tournament from your living room from
your respective bedrooms i'm doing the
same and i'm telling you if i can play
in them when i'm not commentating on
wood so i hope you guys take advantage
of it too
yeah man yeah well i don't know about
you i'm in my super
super tekken studio over here i'm in my
living room what are you talking about
what are you trying to say i'm not like
not wearing pants right now and i'm like
look just wearing a t-shirt but i don't
know what you're talking about look i'm
going to take it around now first off
you need to be proud of that we are
fortunate enough to plan tournaments
without wearing pants you should you
should appraise that moment yeah yeah be
happy about that yeah because once we go
back out and your your comfort zone is
without pants well your perfor the
tournament performance is going to drop
dude this is
wearing jeans anymore i'm gonna just be
real i don't know if jeans is the proper
tournament where i might have to give
you some tournament shorts some
tournament sleeping shorts anyways
speaking of sleep it's almost 4
congratulations that's 4am i'm pretty
sure i just heard a coyote over here but
with that being said i just want to say
one more time petro roses has been a
pleasure shout out to production shout
outs
you know what i'm saying uh and shout
outs to all everybody in the chat man
make sure you give petrol rolls a follow
make sure you follow all the tech and
accounts if you haven't followed me
already make sure you give me a follow
and i'm going to leave the last words to
petrol rose man what do you got and send
these guys home
man i'm just happy to be here i'm like
really excited with what happened and
i'm actually excited for what's to come
so everybody's gonna get ready for the
big top eight the the finals
um i'm i'm excited to watch it and i
wanna see how everybody's gonna adapt
for the future events and yeah man one
day we're gonna be flying out and
meeting up in person and you know and
we've got everybody here supporting us
there now and hopefully in the future
they'll be supporting us even more in
the future so
i'm just looking i'm more i'm looking
into the future optimistically dude i'm
just like ready to go so whatever
whatever's there i'll be there so yeah
man hopefully everybody watching as well
i want to thank for supporting and
watching and you know keeping the chat
hype and you know making the players
feel like you know they're being
you know watched and appreciated for the
performances and yeah man good stuff
very excited man very excited
okay
yo and yeah man and that has been the
second online challenge 2021 for the
oceania region
at masters event complete man and we'll
see you guys next time until then peace
out
dynamic
wow
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]